the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
beautiful surroundings inspired
brilliant play at the superbet chess
classic in Bucharest Romania the
Geniuses of Chess brought their best
ideas hoping to make their Mark in an
exceptional field despite several
chances for decisive results most games
ended in intriguing draws two-time World
Championship Challenger John Napo
miyachi secured a victory defeating
Local Hero Bogdan Daya players are
hitting their strides but the race has
just begun day three of exciting chess
coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back everybody to day three of
the 2023 Superbad chess Classic held in
beautiful Bucharest Romania we started
in front of the Statue of King Carol the
first this is the first king of Romania
a very influential figure in romanian's
history well we have a lot of Kings on
the chessboard let's go to the studio
and find out what they have in store for
us
we welcome you to the first stop on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of superbed Romania we come to you live
from the San Luis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone thanks for
joining us again I am International
master in azify kids and I'm here with
Grandmaster yes
good morning good morning wonderful to
be in studio with you your first two
broadcasts and you have nailed them
you're terrific thank you so much
natural born star hello everyone and
Welcome to our coverage we are in round
three to have gone very very smoothly
and we have three players who have snuck
into the lead well Wesley so started as
a clear leader but he has been joined by
Richard and nepo in fact let's take a
look at all of our standings let's do
the honors right we have three leaders
American Wesley saw Romanian Richard
rapper and representative with one and a
half points absolutely uh with our world
champion dream Lawrence kind of
struggling with two whites two draws
yeah but uh with 50 we have dingliren
from China Dutch number one
mvl from France and American Fabiano
caruana then with half points we have
pollen number one young Christoph Tuda
Romanian Bogdan Daniel diac and from
France
strange to see the number one seed in
last place there and our format
we have a 10 player round robin with
classical time control 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves right 30 minutes for
the rest of the game and 30 second
increment from move one
players are not allowed to offer any
draws and they have a regular scoring
system with one point for a win half for
a draw and zero for a loss and our
schedule for the event
s right we have total of nine rounds and
today we are playing round three yes and
on Thursday May 11th the players will
get a rest day
okay kind of looking forward to that
aren't we already and they'll be back
with four more rounds to go exactly to
complete the tournament 15th and we're
very very happy fortunate to have in
studio version
good morning VAR how are you good
morning yes sir good morning Nazi I'm
very glad to be here so far we had some
very exciting games and I'm looking
forward to the round today and we have
some very very interesting matchups in
particular nepo versus ding
so Jan has a slight lead in this matchup
six wins five losses and 16 draws and of
course these two players just played for
the world championship match and it was
tied after uh the classical portion of
the match they had eight draws three
wins each it was tied to seven to seven
and then in a tie breaks actually
dingler in one two and a half one and a
half he was trailing throughout the
whole match
um and but he managed to equalize in
round number 12 in the game actually
where Yan was about to win and then
pretty much clinched the title and after
that Ding won and tied a match and one
in the playoffs to become the 17th World
chess champion
and we're gonna go to Romania to our
colleague Grandmaster Christian chirilla
good to see you guys and welcome back
chess fans to day three here in
Bucharest Romania at the 2023 super bad
chess classic and what an incredible
start we had to this tournament up to
this point uh yesterday I met with a
high school friend a new chess fan and
he was so excited to see these players
up close he was telling me look this is
like seeing Messi this is like seeing
LeBron James this is like seeing
Cristiano Ronaldo up close is just an
incredible to see the top the elite
Echelon of the players in their
respective fields and this is exactly
what's happening here in Bucharest
Romania take a look at that dingley Wren
getting ready for his big Clash uh a
very known Clash for him he will be
clashing with Jan nepomyashi in the
upcoming minutes and what a Marky
matchup that is I have to say yanepo
miyashi usually he starts off blazing
hot and this is exactly what's happened
in this tournament as well we've seen
how decisive he can be even with the
black pieces yesterday against the
struggling Bogdan Daniel but I have to
say ding you know two draws in the first
couple of games but he generally starts
slow this is very typical of him so
right now round three not so many well
of course a lot of rounds left but still
some rounds behind him he managed to
replenish his energy as he is entering
this Marquee matchup against Jan
napomniashi and another critical matchup
that I'm having my eyes on is the one
between two struggling players in this
one that is Bogdan Daniel the lowest
rated player in the event the Romanian
Prodigy only 21 years of age already a
super Grand Master at 2700 against
another struggling player in this event
Jan shished off Duda and Yasser I mean
you guys were covering uh this game up
close house and you saw how easy it was
for Duda to equalize with the black
pieces against Richie Rapport but then
just a moment of missed attention and
that was it that was all a Richie
Rapport needed to take the full point
home I'm having my eyes on this one the
atmosphere here is electrifying and the
games are about to start well thank you
Christian for the first hand report and
lay the table for our viewers and
actually what are the pairings from
round three right let's take a look at
the pairings we have Fabiano caruana
playing Maxima Sheila Graf happy the
weight match up to be sure and what a
rematch versus ding nice and as
Christian mentioned Duda versus Dia it's
going to be an interesting game number
one see faruga playing one of our
co-leaders Richard Rapport Peru just
looking to climb back into the
competition right and our leader Wesley
so playing anushkiri lots of fights in
store what are they fighting for they
are fighting for a lot of money we have
a price fund of 350 000 the first place
winner is going to get one hundred
thousand dollars nice second place 65
000 third place forty eight thousand
handsome prize fund all the way to 10th
Place ten thousand dollars Grand Chester
points up for grabs you win the
tournament you get a bonus of one point
in the GCT standings remember the end of
the tour the player with the highest gcp
points ends up with a hundred thousand
dollar bonus as well so get those GCT
points early as we see Wesley uh with
the white pieces against arnish Geary
getting ready for their contest and this
today we have two players two persons
pardon me who are going to be making
their first moves and boy oh boy are we
going to be challenged to
properly guess their names
as that's coming up we get ready for the
start of round three
up to three players who are tied for
first uh Wesley nepo and Richard
which three which person has impressed
you most not see so far so far Wesley
has impressed me a lot because he
started with two black pieces exactly
and they were comfortable he was
comfortable he didn't have any issues if
anything he was better even yesterday
correct absolutely and today he has
white pieces we'll see how he does with
whites exactly normally he does really
really well once Italy with there
yeah yeah okay yeah I see it's always
never again the first few minutes right
before you start the game do you get
butterflies in your tummy absolutely the
anticipation right once I make the move
then I calm down exactly right before I
have the butterflies it's amazing I
played probably 4 000 tournament games
and still to this day you know I get how
about you for how do you do deal with
that early anxiety uh just just the
moment prior to the game beginning
yeah yeah so you're a little bit nervous
definitely before the game and uh but
once you start playing once you make
that first move and you play a couple of
rounds it just becomes normal even in a
very very uh top tournament that I
played the US championships in
particular once it starts then you
already slowly get to your wrist now one
guy who never appears to have
butterflies is this guy Richard Rapport
I mean he's the very personification of
California cool like he doesn't I mean
even when he's in time travel he seems
to have he he gives the impression he's
got all the time in the world uh
Richie's special and he is tied for
first once again remind me who is he
playing today
I I got my pairing sheet somewhere in
front of me he's playing alireza yes
the number one seed
this will be this could even though it's
early days and you never really want to
be over the top hyperbole but our
defending grantchester Champion you need
to make a move if you will uh I think it
has warmed up and he's white too so uh
big big challenge of course in front of
Rishi
yes welcome everybody
round three
and that's about it
[Music]
today where we see again the one-time
match here in Bucharest together with
other four great chess duels I'm sure
we'll have today just a short
introduction
to hospitals foreign
Royal
[Music]
man united properties
I didn't quite pick up the name uh this
is my says my her Michael or Mahal
the jewelry of
yes
yes he is the CEO of one United
and he will be playing uh your first
move for nepo
he likes it oh no he doesn't like that
and uh also to make an opening move we
will have a soccer player from Romania
bump down
yes it is
[Music]
being
he was at the World Cup he won Titans
I think he has played in the soccer
World Cup wow
okay and you want to make a move for
Duda
three he's definitely not gonna like
that one no no no that one's gonna get
pulled back that's for sure nice
[Applause]
of the room and black to our discipline
scene the third round of super matches
are still not at the board yeah I'm
missing uh Ali razor
normally his uh not purple but his
Blazer is a real eye-catching color it's
obviously
um
watch a device
[Music]
even though every round is going to be
featuring great matchups when you look
across the field and see the
theoreticians sitting at the board what
are you anticipating for round three
where's the big Clash well I'm
definitely looking forward to the clash
between Yan and Dink because I think
definitely uh Jana is gonna try to put
some pressure and try to win it maybe
get a little bit of Revenge from the
world championship match so definitely
my eyes will be on that game and I also
want to see the matchup between caruana
and mvl because if Fabi wants to try to
win this tournament he needs to try to
score a win today with the white pieces
um yesterday Envia was the first to
admit that his opening wasn't successful
whereas I think Fabi has brought some
pretty impressive opening play thus far
in the first two rounds
yeah as always Fabi is always extremely
well prepared yes yes
and we're and by the way uh I have to
confess my pick dingler in uh two two uh
White pieces only two draws as our world
champion is now
thrown back if you will to the world
championship these guys haven't played
enough yes exactly exactly we need more
games from them this is game number 13
game number 15 right right yeah and uh
how do you think their preparation went
like for today's game do they have more
tricks left for each other you know it's
the craziest thing but when I worked
with both Jan Timon and Victor korchnine
for their world championship matches I
really always had this sense
that so much was not shown we worked on
so many positions and we only you know
like you uh touched on a couple of key
um contests and it's very strange you
don't it's like this world championship
matches have their own
energy and
um even though you're looking at a lot
of different openings and a lot of
different things you don't know where
the major conversation is going to be by
the way Knight C3 on me move three
inviting a nimzo Indian and also Nepal
most of the match played E4 and here we
are seeing D4 exactly so here you kind
of get this idea like whoa you know the
ambidextrous nepo uh what is he how is
he going to meet Bishop B4 and uh what
would he play if you played D5 you know
is he going to play Bishop G5 a
conventional Queen's Gambit decline I
think we had at least one ninja game in
the world championship match maybe two
jump in VAR uh how many
H4 yeah yeah this is a game I wanted to
uh talk about guys Fabi is definitely
showing that he's gonna play very
ambitious chess so he played the move H4
this move was actually popular a couple
of years ago but it's interesting to see
what is Fabi is going to bring to to
this game and definitely a little bit of
surprise here with cmvl is thinking and
uh been very impressed with fabi's
preparation as yesterday you mentioned
with black pieces he had an interesting
idea against uh Ding and made a draw
without any problems so let's see how
this game will develop we can look at
some of the lines here after H4 for
example uh Bishop G7 is one option
here and we see a lot of games played by
Magnus Carlson mvl ding actually with
white pieces and if Knight C3
for example then uh again lots of moves
here you can play D6 the one of the main
ideas is if you play the move D5 here I
can take Knight takes D5 and I can play
this move H5 immediately then the pawn
on H5 you have threads like H6
oftentimes you just put a Pawn on H6 and
it's it's very unpleasant uh because the
Palm will be sitting there and uh
getting a lot of space so this is one
option here if you play the move D5 if
you just play D6
then there is a possibility of just
playing the move E4 and then you play
Bishop E2 and possibly H5 after at some
point you you definitely want to play
that move H5 to create some pressure
there well sorry I I mean
it's funny when I started playing chess
I mean my opening move was H4 and Rook
H3 and A4 and Rook A3 and when my
opponents kept capturing my Rooks you
know I had to alter my strategy later
when I became let's say a 1200 player
the move H4 was all together frowned
upon you just couldn't play H4 and I see
this move today in the 23rd century and
I go my goodness I mean you know that's
a beginner's move why is it not a
beginner's move why is it suddenly
incredibly popular
uh I think also yesterday we we were
talking about that Alpha zero uh earlier
today and uh in a lot of the games we
saw that happening you know white would
just play H4 H5 H6 and put the pawn out
there and leave it for maybe another 15
20 moves and later on we see that it's
very difficult for black to play When
the pawn is actually on H6 and uh just
also you know create some interesting uh
ideas different ideas so we're not
playing the good main groom fed lines or
the king's Indian for example I also
think that these players top players
have such difficulty getting an
advantage with white pieces because
everyone is so well prepared right if
you go to the conventional route exactly
you get nothing so sometimes you have to
go and think outside the box and go with
H4 and move three well that's just crazy
okay so let me take a counter or yeah
I'll play The Devil's Advocate if you
will and I'll say because H4 does not
seek to control the center I'm going to
say it's a bad move full stop and I I'm
going to blow you away as black I'm
going to take the most Ultra aggressive
stance I can and I'm going to go C5 I'm
going to attack you in the center
and I'm presume you're going to play D5
yeah because I mean if you go E3 and
Knight F3 after H4 yeah exactly and so
I'm gonna play a Banco Gambit where
you know you've kind of committed
yourself to a move that maybe in a Banco
Gambit you're not completely happy
oftentimes in a Banco Gambit you play
like H3 G3 Bishop G2 you know like so
you've already
weakened if you will your control of the
G4 square and so the idea in the benko
Gambit is I want to offer a pawn but
I also am am you know laughing at your
H5 attacking ideas yes please I'm 100
sure both of them have looked at this
opening I am absolutely sure as well
Bishop G7 Knight C3 on the board and
VAR again let me pick your brain a
little bit here after Knight C3 Bishop
G7
does it make any sense for black to
transpose into a king's Indian defense
after say D6 E4 where once again white
has made a H4 but let's take let's take
a break and throw it over to Romania uh
with Christian's leading sustainable
thank you Yasser we are here with mihai
pedroyo CEO of commercial real estate at
one United properties one of our uh very
important sponsors here at Superbad
chess classic first of all mihai welcome
to the show tell us a bit about this
partnership
so um one of the founders of one United
properties which is the leading
sustainable mixed use developer um
project in Romania
is very keen on chess he's a very big
fan of Chess and
this is how being a long time friend of
Mr dragic
we joined this initiative and we became
one of the the supporters
of also the Romanian Chess Federation
and this competition how would you say
one United's strategy connects with
chess in what ways
well
um as a listed company we take all ESG
components extremely seriously
as I said we are the leading green
developer in Romania
but going forward we believe that
the key to progress the key to
development
in any society
especially an emerging one like Romania
is education and therefore as much as we
can and we are able to we invest and we
support
initiatives that are related to
education
We Believe chess is
is is
more than um
let's say a recreational activity we
believe that it it structures and it
shapes a young player's mind Vision it
provides balance and this is a great
alternative to to traditional education
and we believe that chess can really
enhance
anyone's uh
life through
development of thought process logic and
and so on so this is why we believe that
we we should support this and we will
always try to to promote chess as as a
movement especially
across
young Generations speaking of education
and the Young Generation how important
it is for the up and coming generation
to see the best chess players here in
Bucharest I think it's amazing even for
me as uh you know let's say a
amateur non-member of this
professional movement let's say to be
able to to see the world champion
playing live and
to see this diversity of really
bright Minds is a unique opportunity and
it's a it's an experience that we we
didn't have access to before so I think
everyone is very fortunate and very
thankful
for being able to to take part into into
such an event and also to have it here
in in Romania now I'm going to put you
on the spot who is your favorite player
in this event well of course I have to
support
our Romanian player which is Bogdan so I
hope he does really well and I hope he
wins points for Romania
but again I think all players are are
extremely talented and uh
it's an honor to to have them here mihai
thank you for coming on the show and
thank you for your continued support
thank you guys back to you thank you
Christian thank you Michael as uh the
games are underway and across the board
we're seeing a lot of diverse openings
this is
I love it and in the game between Fabi
and mvl mvl's approach has been to take
it to a king's Indian an offer box
system with Bishop E2 now in an offer
box system with Bishop E2 one that I
used to play instead of the inclusion of
the move H4 I would have my Bishop on
GT5 now in this particular case I very
often followed it up with H4 after I
after I had provoked H6 or something
like that so the move H4 actually fits
and somehow
um it probably has not been punished for
making this early
I think you'll be very happy to see the
next few moves C5 D5 I did play B5 B5
okay
nice I think this is a somehow you have
to challenge this move H4 because if we
just go back to this position after for
example Bishop E2 if you were to play a
conventional just uh 97 97 wonderful and
I play H5 you play E5 I suppose yeah uh
D5
995 I suppose uh Bishop F3 guess what
you've transposed into a Mainline uh
system where you might say White's got a
kind of an attack uh White is ready to
capture Play Bishop to H6 and with a
half open H file why to sacrifice
nothing on the contrary as good Central
play oh it's definitely going to Castle
long yes yes yes uh so he's got
something now conversely the way uh the
game has gone uh I like this this
approach of Banco and King's Indian
right now yes is there a name for I
think it's actually transposes into a
Benco but with H4 but with H4 which is a
move that doesn't often fit with a Banco
after the move A4
as black you you pretty much want to
take here why you can't take with the
Knight that would just simply hang the
E4 Pawn you can't take with the ape on
because well it's pinned so you're going
to have to play Bishop E2 takes B5 so
you've kind of gone Bishop F1 to E2
takes B5 and for those of you who do
play the benko Gambit uh you're very
happy to see white take these Tempe
along and normally speaking again if
this Pawn were on H2 let's say and this
Knight for whatever reasons we're on F3
you'd be that much closer to castling
the fact that White's King is in the
center still kind of suggests to me it's
time to try to break things open with E6
E7 E6 either E6 or maybe bishop A6 which
is another typical typical Banker uh VAR
uh Jump Right In Here what's the
theoretical
outcome uh these are two heavyweight
theoreticians they've had this position
on their board at home and one of their
engines taught them
yeah definitely yes sir this uh players
are familiar with this position there
are some games we can check actually mvl
had a game with the white pieces in this
position now he's playing with the black
pieces here so let's take a look at some
of the lines now
um so again it's like a benko opening
and A4 is a very important move actually
in this position to make sure when you
capture back with the bishop you can
have the recapture here so after Bishop
A6 here uh Fabi took on A6 there are
other options here two Bishop B2 in
particular was played before uh in the
game mvl against swindler the idea of
Bishop B2 is that when you capture white
actually can take back with the pawn and
if you take on A1 now you can recapture
with the queen right so again this also
playable position black will play in
ipd7 and uh very small Advantage here
but not so much I think black has enough
Contra play but in the game we saw the
move Bishop takes A6 and definitely uh
still a prep and Knight takes A6 plate
so instead of Bishop D2 We have Knight
takes A6 and here I think we're gonna
see the move Knight F3 here developing
the Knight and trying to Castle and one
of the main ideas here would be to try
to after that prepare the move E5 for
example Knight before we could see
castle and for a long time now with H5
we're not going to see them of H5 as
long as the Knight is on F6 this Pawn is
going to remain on H4 here and after
let's say queen D7 white will just
continue with the normal developing move
Bishop G5 so the engines are showing a
slightly better position here for white
but I think uh black has some counter
play the Knight on B4 is well placed
thank you for um yeah intriguing
intriguing uh game there is somehow this
move H4 I'm still tasered by it like
it's just standing there and and uh so
on uh where would you like to go uh
let's check real quick Wesley so on
nishikiri's game absolutely I always
like to check in on our leader or and or
co-leader
um very conventional yes Berlin I mean
yeah boy I but Bishop B4 is a little bit
off
[Music]
exactly I myself included Bishop E7 very
very often black is looking there's
Knight on F5 in a sense if you were to
take the Knight on F5 and the Knight on
F3 take that pair of knights off the
board that is black you would very
quickly Play Bishop F5 and you go hey
I've got a nice development I'm hitting
the pawn on C2 so the move Bishop E7 is
the most conventional move as a knight
H4 seeks to trade Bishop B4 on the other
hand
well if it's my turn I guess I'm going
to capture that and I'm going to put my
Bishop as quickly as I possibly can
right in the center of the board on the
D5 square and laugh at any attempts by
white uh trying to come up with an
advantage so if I were a wide here I
would probably play 94. okay to avoid
the exchange makes a lot of sense to me
as well now one of the things I'm a
little bit worried about is that my
pieces kind of jam up it's sort of like
again I'm not satisfied with the night
on on uh F5 but I would like to reroute
my pieces a little bit my Bishop on B4
looks a little bit funny I might play
moves like Knight to E7
I like that idea with the idea of maybe
I'm going to tickle your night on e4
with Bishop F5 but another very
conventional approach too is just to sit
there and go okay
why did you put your your Bishop out
over here
um the Berlin what can I say I mean the
engines approve it and even when I think
I'm doing well with white I look at the
engines it goes from 0.3 and it's like
oh no
but I like seeing still new moves even
in Berlin right sorry I like seeing new
moves in Berlin of course still seeing
some new ideas in this by the way yeah
on the board
um I wanted to say that deox move I'm
really uh mystified here uh the
russellimo uh has been played for
basically uh decades uh Nikolai Nicholas
rosalima Nicola Russell limo from New
York City
um trailblaze the move of his name
Bishop B5 often times
white voluntarily plays the move Bishop
takes C6 so a lot of this opening in the
match world championship match between
Magnus and Fabi right precisely
when Fabi determined that the open uh
specialnikov was not bringing the bacon
he went for the rossolimo and boy A7 A6
wow that I mean diac played a move that
a surprise move for me where you take
the tempo oftentimes white is again
voluntarily capturing uh it was a Tempo
h2h3 Knight F6 and I need to get vars uh
expert opinion on this theoretical
position A7 A6 VAR is that good
it's it's just a rare move actually the
Knight F6 is the main move in that
position Yasser and I actually yeah the
the idea of Bishop B5 is to try to take
on C6 and by encouraging on A6 it seems
like this might be uh slightly
inaccurate but there are some games
played and we can check some of the
lines now we see about 34 games in a
database in the current position Here
and Now rookie one is played actually
there is a move very interesting move
here Queen D3 here to try to prevent
white from playing D4 uh the queen is
going to get pushed back here but at
least now The Rook is going to be a
little bit on an awkward Square so now
after rookie 3 you can play either back
on the 8th or even Queen D7 here and uh
now you play D3 and the game continues
Castle
um and The Rook is actually misplaced it
you're gonna have to actually bring the
Rook back only one at some point so one
of the main lines would be to go rookie
one try to get the bishop out to F4 or
G5 but then Rook d8 comes in and the
queen is actually not that bad here on
D7 because now you're putting pressure
on D3 and sort of forcing the move E5
here because there's no good way to
protect the pawn on D3 so E5 we can see
Knight D5 and some interesting ideas
with the move E6 so position is pretty
complicated here why it's not developed
at all the coincide right I I I I hear
loud and clear all right the whole Queen
side is still on the first rank in that
position you're showing and
Nasi and I are both are both like wow
you know like why are you investigating
this these lines as white uh no Queen D3
no Queen D3 uh straightforward castles
the move c2c3 suggests to me that Duda
both players needing a win it's time to
play D4 right
and I think you can play it right now
why delayed right right I mean you he's
made all of his preparations for you
know the central Pond Duo Ken black uh
take on D4 and play C5 with the other
Pawn okay so C5 takes D4 C3 takes D4 by
the way we're still in the theoretical
the well-charted waters C5 kind of it's
like a benoni kind of a position I would
I would consider this but again you are
uh
going to get back the pawn on e4 but I
would go with the conventional D5 did
you want to follow us up with these
things yeah I was going to say uh it's a
rare transition to go from Sicilian to
benoni right right yeah you I I know
what you're doing is you're comparing
your opening sheets from one to the
other but you are allowing a protected
passport on D6 in this case so I could
play Bishop G5 I'm threatening E5 right
you're almost obliged to play H6 now
uh uh oof look at those ponds yeah but
two Bishops you can undermine maybe B5
very quickly or yeah you know it's
it's it's not an automatically great
advantage or anything it's hard to tell
here which one's better two nights or
two Bishops yeah but it's all about that
protected asset or liability okay so and
I I was just being a little bit flippant
with the move Bishop G5 but if I had
played Knight C3 it almost feels like
some lines of the groom fell too we talk
about benoni Sicilian uh intriguing I
have a protected past Pawn
what do you have I will play Bishop F4
Queen D2
um how do you feel
I'm liking what you're liking white me
too I think so as well so we'll see if
he follows up with uh C3 uh
um a game that we highlighted at the
start of the show a rematch from the
recent world championship match between
nepo and ding uh let's show our respects
here
um whoa I'm a little bit surprised to
see ding play this line of the Queen's
Gambit declined early Bishop F5 yeah
that's okay but the fact that he does it
without the move h7h6o a question that
normally speaking I play this as black
myself but I like to include H6
Bishop F5 and we could transpose very
quickly to the game position
the entire difference being that I've
given my Bishop one extra Square my Pawn
is on H6 it's oftentimes happened that
whites plays H4 in these positions and
the bishop would be trapped now in the
game position
with the pawn still on H7 the move H4 is
often played because you can trap the
bishop and H4 often and if white that's
why H4 does black respond with H6 or H5
usually H6 H5 ends up being after Knight
H3
um yeah it starts to get targeted but
ever since a fantastic game between
Magnus Carlson and Vladimir Kramden
there's been some dark clouds over uh
this uh position this whole approach
because in that game white took a very
slow laborious when of play and Vladimir
kramnik got completely outplayed by
Magnus Carlson
um this line is considered a bit too
passive for the black pair player VAR a
is that a correct assessment
yeah it's a little bit passive but you
still have a lot of games played by a
top ground Masters in fact this move A5
play biting is actually a very rare move
is it so yeah a very rare move actually
the main move in this position is the
move Knight D7 I will show you some
lines now so in this position I actually
played this once with black as well
against a very strong Grandmaster Le
Quang Liam and uh you have to be really
careful you're right because if white
somehow gets a blockade on F5 and trade
the right pieces you could be in a
serious trouble here so the main move in
this position is to play Knight D7 and
we have you know over 200 games played
in this position and uh the usually the
game will continue like Knight H4 and
then Bishop E7 and uh black really wants
to play the move F5 attacking the Knight
and at some point you will put the
Knight on F6 here so Knight E2 for
example here F5 and you never really
want to take on G6 because once you take
on G6 you'll just help black to fix the
on structure here so you will have to
play either Knight F3 back or often
times you also can play the move G3 here
and then we have some positions like
this bishop H4 Pawn takes H4 and then
you play the move Knight F6 Bishop looks
very very bad right now on G6 but it's
not so easy to make progress here and
this position is actually very slightly
better for white but in the game we have
the move A5 very rare move as I
mentioned the null Knight H4 is played
and here's A4 now just play by Ding and
it's pretty clear what he wants to do
here he wants to move uh the Palm to A3
and create some weaknesses so I think
very important and I think we're
probably going to see the move A3 here
played to prevent that and also fix the
pawn on A4 I'm not sure about putting
the pawn on A4 because I feel like at
some point this might be a weakness so
after a four white is a little bit
better here according to the computers
after the move A3 here okay go ahead and
play A3 for just a second VAR yes after
the move A3 and I see the computer wants
to play Bishop E7 and and B5
if it was White's move so let's just say
for argument's sake Knight D7 yeah
reasonable is the move F4 oh it
absolutely because that Bishop on G6
looks like a attempting Target right
that you know you don't want to play F5
and get hit with Bishop to D3 so a
little awkward absolutely yeah this is a
slightly better position for white and
now you have to play either the move F5
or H5 and uh both cases you're not going
to be very happy once you play the move
F5 I can play let's say Bishop B3
precise and now here actually black is
already sacrificing the pawn and looking
for some control play with the move B5
and Bishop takes F5 Knight to B6 right
and tonight Knight Knight will be
actually very well placed here on C4 and
but again white is happy he's just upper
upper full Pawn here there might be some
compensation but white is just better
here and if you play the move instead of
F5 here you try because you need you
need something against F5 here so you
need to get a square for the bishop here
so let's say you play the move H5 here
then I think y can play F5 right pushing
the bishop to H7 very passive squares
and here's just King F2 for example
and then develop the bishop on D3 and uh
White is better here for example Bishop
page six Bishop D3
it looks like black is playing down a
piece because Bishop on H7 is terrible I
I remember I forcibly reminded of a
modern day tragedy even on sokolov
somehow he got his Bishop trapped on H7
and then it was like even he had like
Rooks on G it was just horrifying what
happened and he ended up losing his
white
um I'm a little bit uh skeptical of of
Black's position we'll see how things
unfold excuse me
I wanted to say uh we want to invite you
to join our conversation the stump Nasi
bar and myself and you can join the
conversation by you can send it send us
tweets at grandchester super bad chess
classic or you can also send your
questions on Twitch YouTube Instagram
Facebook we have a lot of channels and
our social media is managed by Anastasia
so she will be looking out for your
questions and we got some really good
ones yesterday so we encourage you and
let's see where else would you like to
take us let's take a look at ferocious
game uh page four different position I
tell you uh the
the Russian defense or the Petrov as we
say in the United States it's one of
those uh defenses that has uh come in
and out of fashion over the years and I
think every world champion at one time
or another including the very Dynamic
Gary Kasparov has used the Russian
defense in their repertoire but at the
club level it's not really that popular
I guess it gets a reputation of being
too solid and just like Berlin yeah but
now having said that at the very very
high professional levels especially with
nepos extraordinary success as black in
his handling uh more and more players
including the very creative Richie
Rapport are saying you know
okay I like the Petrov I like the
Russian defense h2h4
what do we say about those apples uh VAR
that looks hyper aggressive
actually a report played a very rare
move this move Bishop F5 there were a
few other options a lot more theoretical
almost in that position yeah but this
bishop P5 is very rare we can check some
of the lines now so in this position
here we have almost three thirteen
hundred games played and the main move
here is Bishop E6
about 900 games played and a lot of a
lot of top players play with this move
and also we have the move Castle in here
and the Knight E5 so these are the three
options here but he played Bishop F5 the
fourth move and uh there are some games
I can see especially the Chinese
Grandmaster Yu yangi played this against
uh mvl he made a draw and actually won
against nepo in 2019. I'm not sure
whether or not this was a classical game
or a blitz or rapid but Bishop F5 now we
have uh long Castle
which is very logical and now Queen D7
black is just trying to prepare the long
Castle as well because oftentimes if you
cast a short white will play H4 H5 and
prepare the advance of the pawns to
create some attacking chances here
so now we have A3 plate
and this castle and H4 as soon as we see
a short Castle this is a typical idea we
play the move H4 now we have some H5
ideas to play H6 and also sometimes we
can put a knight on G5 as well here
so at the moment
black has many options you can play Rook
f8 for example very logical move and
then white can play Bishop D3
and let's say if we exchange the Bishops
after Queen D3 you always have to watch
out for the move Knight to G5 here and
if you put a Pawn on H6 we know that
sometimes this could be a problem
because now this Pawn will become a hook
and if white can prepare the move G4 G5
then you have to react so it's not ideal
to have the pawn on H6 in this position
so you can play perhaps Bishop two F6
here and here white can't even play the
move let's say Bishop G5 now trying to
double up the pawns and it's not easy to
play this like for example the best move
here is to play Queen G4 but it's a
little bit counter-intuitive to allow
for example Bishop F6 GTX F6 in this
position so this should be very
interesting game and definitely firusha
is trying to play aggressively to try to
get on a scoreboard and to try to get to
the 50
absolutely uh Alert in the dingler end
game because
I was worried From ding's perspective
that the move Knight H4 was a Prelude to
F4 right and that if white could get in
the move F4
that the danger that this bishop could
get trapped and we just saw a line where
the vision went down to H7 it was pretty
ridiculous there
I thought the move Bishop E7 was more or
less a blight obligatory in the sense
that F4 could be met by F5 yeah with a
very important Tempo driving the night
back so you don't have the time to play
Bishop D3 if I don't care Knight takes
F5 ding played Knight D7 a move that
well you know immediately you start to
look and go lucky lucky F4 uh F5 as we
as was mentioned you know you can you
can try to make some suggestion that
well the Knight on C4 it's a pawn it's a
pawn I'll take on G6 with the Knight I
will uh bring my Bishop back to D3 and I
say okay Bishop's above opposite color
all right sure sure we still have a lot
of other pieces on the board right
exactly I I'll I'd like to play White
and see about my winning chances
contrarily to that if you do play a move
like H6 or H5 F5
I will not sign up any way shape or form
I'd rather be down upon them yeah seven
that just makes a woeful impression and
that move Knight D7 maybe it's engine
approved and I'm just like uh like
scratching my head uh VAR but I did ding
uh mess up with the move Knight D7
I think so yes sir I think 97 actually
inaccurate I like your suggestion of the
move Bishop E7 and I checked that if you
play Bishop E7 you're not afraid of the
move F4 anymore because you have to move
F5 right so I don't like the move 97
that much because I think after the move
F4 he's gonna have to sacrifice a pawn
uh in that line to play B5 Knight B6 to
try to get some kind of counter play
because otherwise position is very
passive we can check again uh to see if
there are some other options you can do
so now F4
can blacklight Bishop E4 Bishop E4 let's
take a look here Bishop B4 of
it could be it could be this might be
his best move but again it looks it
doesn't look that good I think Knight
takes E4 right Pawn takes E4 and I like
this idea of G3 the G3 which I with the
with the idea Bishop G2 just simply to
attack the Pawn King F2 is another good
move here
um you can also play G4 at some point
it's this pause structure looks really
bad it's it's very hard to connect the
pawns and I I like I like this move G3
let's say now uh five is going to be a
lore yeah it's going to be boss yeah now
for example Rook A5 you have to play
okay and I guess the point is now if you
play Bishop G2 F5
Bishop H3 and now Rook B5 but again you
already have to play this creative way
not to just lose the game here and
apparently this is okay for black
because it's very hard to protect the B2
and if you play Rook B1 you're gonna run
into the bishop A3 tactic clear but
again if you have to play Rook a 5 Rook
B5 this this doesn't look that great
here so you know we don't have to play
the move Bishop G2 here it's possible to
play uh King E2 here even King E2 is a
suggestion here uh or King F2 and now
you're controlling the B5 square right
now so there is no Rook B5 at the moment
and if F5 is played then follow it up
with Bishop H3 now putting pressure on
F5 and if you play the move now Rook B5
we already can play uh
we have an unexpected move on the board
uh nepo did play F4 and Dink responded
with Bishop C2 Bishop yes this doesn't
look good guys the evaluation jumped
almost plus two now and he played with
nipple quickly too yeah ding seems to be
in his preparation hard how good or
otherwise is it's been ding's
preparation Bishop C2 yes okay obviously
he's thinking that his Bishop will be
anchored on B3 very very nice but having
said that the bishop on B3 will no
longer be controlling so for example
just let's let's make a few moves it
will no longer be controlling the F5
square and that Knight looks just loving
that night
oh it's just a thought it's better than
an extra Pawn actually guys there is
something really specific why this
bishop C2 move is bad here and it's not
that easy to spot I will show you so you
actually need to start with this move
Rook C1 here first okay instead of King
D2 looks very logical the answer but you
need that D2 Square for another piece
here so we start out with the move Rook
C1 and back in the bishop and again
you're not going to go back to E4 now
because you just lost the tempo you can
go back to G6 because after F5 you're
going to lose the bishop you go back to
Bishop B3 here and this is probably the
idea he thought he will have a secure
Bishop here but now here is actually
incredible move here Knight B1 right and
now you want to put the Knight on D2 and
just take the bishop on B3 here and uh
you really have to play the move C5 here
to generate some kind of counter play
otherwise after Knight D2 I will just
simply take the bishop follow it up with
Rook C3 and pick up the pawn on B3 so
but looks like C5 doesn't work here
either because if you play the smooth C5
D takes C5
now you have two options how to
recapture you can take back with the
Knight or Bishop if you take back with
the bishop now the Knight has this
wonderful Square on F5 it's an outpost
there is no way for you to remove this
knight from here you don't have any pawn
moves and your Bishop is actually out of
place so you cannot really attack it and
if Bishop B6
for example and now Knights will come to
D2 getting ready now to capture the
bishop on B3 and it's terrible yeah this
this is really bad Knight C5 this is
like playing the best moves for black
imagine you play all these moves and
still it looks absolutely terrible
Bishop B5 check King d8 and now simply
white will put the King on F2 here
connecting the Rooks and this is almost
a winning position now for white I have
a question for you so we do have a rook
C1 on the board and Bishop B3 so we'll
see if Jan finds Knight B1 but could he
do the same idea with another Knight
let's say Knight F3 and 92. I was also
thinking about that and I think there is
a difference now if you start with that
move here if you play the move Knight F3
here
uh the idea now is black can play the
move B5
and the difference was when you move the
Knight on B1 you cannot play the move B5
because then you have the you have the
CC you have the C6 spawn hanging so
that's why if you play Knight yeah 92
Bishop C4 this looks okay yes but if we
go back to the Knight B1 move in this
position if you play now B5 You're
simply dropping the pawn on C6
all right so we'll see very subtle move
9v1 but if Nepal finds it I I think he
might just win this game well it's it's
one of the Strategic tactical ideas uh
uh that it's conventional in the sense
that white white uh tracking down the
bishop whether it be on G6 whether it be
on B3 and uh Knight B1 has a very
logical undertone to it so I will expect
that Knight B1 uh nepo's familiar with
this uh whole idea concept and
definitely attempting moose in this
position true I'm just thinking that
Ding uh what a what what a poor start
two draws with uh in the first two
rounds with white pieces and already
this looks like a very bad opening
position and maybe this is the first
time that somebody has really gotten a
very bad opening yeah I think so yeah
like uh people are trying their best to
squeeze out a small Advantage but this
one looks pretty pretty big
um Wesley so let's just jump to our
early tournament leader 92 Bishop E6
Knight D4 uh takes takes Bishop to D5 I
mean she's saying hey look tell me what
you got I've got the two Bishops uh do
nothing for another move or two and I
have no problems whatsoever with black
uh rook d8 and Wesley
are we still in conventional Theory VAR
uh because I'm looking at the position
I don't see any particular Advantage not
so much Theory anymore Yasser but four
moves uh four games played in this
position yeah Bishop before was a pretty
rare move but we discussed that already
in in the opening so most people play
the move Bishop E7 in this position
right but the current position played
only four times and I think black is
doing okay here we can check some of the
lines in a current position now sure and
uh so here we have Rook d8 was just
played I think uh it's a lot it's a
logical move and here white can play for
example you can play the move C3
now attacking the bishop then Bishop C5
you don't really want to put a bishop on
E7 here because then you're gonna run
into the move Knight F5 which is going
to be unpleasant and here if you play G6
you're actually losing an exchange so
you have to be careful about that and
you will pay them all Bishop C5
in this position and um now the best
movie is actually to play B4 but that
will allow Bishop takes deforge
and if you take what the pawn black is
absolutely fine this bishop is
incredibly strong on D5 so you're
probably gonna need to take with the
Rook if you're trying to get some
Advantage but it looks just just equal
after Bishop E6 here now trying to trade
pair of the Rooks here you play Rook 81
Rook takes D4
Rook takes D4 and here actually you
don't want to take on A2 this is very
important if you take this pawn and I
will play Bishop G5 and you're in
serious trouble and once again we have
to remind everyone that black cannot
Castle because you actually move the
king if you can Castle here you'll be
absolutely fine here and here it's a
trouble because you have to play the
move F6 but if you don't take on A2 here
you just simply play the move King E7
now if Bishop G5 played you will just
play F6
captures GTX F6 and black is absolutely
fine here Bishop F4 for example Bishop
A2 Bishop C7 and most likely this game
end will end in a draw actually
absolutely uh by the way nepo did play
the move Knight B1 the move that we were
advocating and thanks to the magic of
Television we can show you how he did it
and he knocked his game
in uh the process there you must be
quite nervous too yeah she can't feel
that he's better now he's much better
yes and uh for the are you are you
familiar and
oh we had a viewer poll we had two two
and a half thousand voters who's going
to win today it's it's quite evenly
defined yeah I was about to say our uh
our posters uh got it one third one
third one but they haven't seen Knight
B1 on the board yeah I think if you
updated that poll uh nepo's chances are
jumping from soaring from 31 like 75 80
now I would yeah for sure and I'd like
uh the the the producer Tom to replay
that that that video of the king getting
knocked over for just a moment by the
Blazer by the Blazer by the jacket
because this actually happens a lot and
I've got this great story to explain
how you could use this to Advantage
the king gets knocked over and of course
you adjust the king you put it back on
the Square before you press the clock
how do I say it would be an illegal
movement exactly
so a famous uh game of uh Amos Byrne
it's called the pipe King are you
familiar with the pipe Game No so at one
time you could smoke at the chessboard
and uh burn light the pipe right so he
had his pipe thing and you know all the
tobacco and everything set up over there
and he was given a situation
where he could sacrifice a night
could sacrifice a night
but the combination
only works if the king is adjusted in
the corner but his Knights under attack
if he makes the move King H1 just makes
the move his opponent will say what are
you doing you're leaving your night on
Parade
oh if I take it this and this and this
will happen
so what Byrne did is he reached for his
pipe
yeah and he got it all and his jacket
knocked over the king
so he just adjusted the king and his
opponent's a touch move touch move touch
move
you have to move your king no it was an
accident no no no you have to move your
king everybody saw a touch move you have
to move it oh dear you know so very
reluctantly he moves his King slaps the
clock the opponent happily takes the
Knight and falls into the combination
that wins for burn
but if he didn't knock over his King if
he had just made the move his opponent
would have been alerted and realized he
couldn't take the Knight
a lucky accident exactly
uh let's jump to Bucharest in a quick
update from Christian what do you have
first Christian
thanks guys so I just came uh back from
the playing venue and I have to say
there are so much tension in here
specifically aimed at this game between
Jan nepomniashi and dingley Ren and
we've seen how nervous perhaps how
nervous Jan is and he was also walking a
lot at the beginning of the round not
facing his opponent but he definitely
was the one that got the first surprise
of this game in as early as move one
because as you guys mentioned he played
E4 in uh for the whole duration of the
world championship match and right now
he switches so this move d4 definitely
came as a huge surprise for uh dingley
Ren and I have to say from a practical
perspective I was not happy with the way
ding approached this opening for example
take a look at this
after the move E3 this is very very
typical Bishop to F5 in my opinion and
sure it's objectively a very good
position but you're allowing white to
start the game towards this end game
that this type of end game that we're
seeing right now on the board which I
have to say from a practical perspective
it's extremely difficult to play
especially if you haven't studied it
before the game and we know that Jan
most likely looked at this variation as
it is one of the most topical if I would
have been in ding's shoes at this point
I would have stopped and I would have
played it in a more classical way with
Bishop to E7 or Knight to D7 just the
typical car spot structure way Bishop to
E7 Castle 97 rookie 8 Knight f8 things
of that nature and sure maybe white has
a slight Advantage but is not going to
be as decisive as it was in the game and
take a look at what happened Bishop
takes F6 Queen F6 and Knight to F3 sure
white can also play with H4 ideas which
provokes the move H6 or H5 to stop white
from taking more center with more space
with H5 but what he did was Knight to F3
very typical and now A5 and this was the
first move for which ding spent a lot of
time he spent around seven minutes at
this point once again signaling the fact
that he's not aware of what he needs to
be doing in this particular opening and
you see how fast this position can go
downhill for uh Black Knight to H4 A4
makes some sense right yeah as black
you're trying to take advantage space
advantage on the queen side but you're
also at the same time creating a lot of
weaknesses and right now it feels like
you want to defend that weakness the
newly created weakness on A4 with the
move Bishop to C2 the problem is after
Bishop to C2 Rook to C1 Bishop to B3 and
you feel like finally your Bishop is
safe on B3 you're not going to be able
to attack it yeah sure right Jan
immediately spotted it and I have a
feeling he probably had this type of
positions in his preparation at home as
well play the move Knight to be one of
the best move in the position and right
now I have to say he's enjoying a
decisive Advantage Jan is a man on a
mission yesterday when he came for the
interview he said that my goal right now
is to get to 2800. if he wins today
against England he will touch that
elusive Spot 2 800 rating just an
incredible feature and right now as you
can see look at Jan he's confident he
senses the moment the gravitas of this
moment and right now the pressure all
the pressure is on uh Ding and in the
game between Fabiano and Maxim
I want to touch on the opening as well
as the position that we are in right now
uh we've seen this move H4 by
um Fabiano early on H4 now this is
clearly aimed against the grunfeld right
because if you do play the move D5 then
I can just simply take on D5 there's no
Knight on C3 this is very very important
we see this type of idea with ah4 very
often after Knight to C3 D5 and now H4
but now I can just simply play the move
Bishop to G7 and if you do take on G5 I
take on uh D5 excuse me not on G5 on D5
and now there's a knight on C3 so for
example if you try to continue with the
move H5 I go C5 and you cannot take on
C5 because the Knight on C3 is going to
be hanging if there's no Knight if
there's no target on C3 then black is
just going to throw blank bullets at
White's Center so you cannot go C5
because I'm just going to take on C5
without the Knight on C3 very important
detail in this position so that's why
white starts with the move H4 at move
three right now once again D5 not a very
good idea he plays Bishop to G7 and of
course we see Fabiano as saying his
typical
um very good preparation and he has a
lot of time advantage on the clock as we
are entering this position at move 13
and black played the move Queen to G4
this is a very crucial position
now we see one uh of the disadvantages
of playing an early H4 you cannot Target
that Queen on G4 with the move H3 right
so that Queen on G4 has a pretty nice
Outpost but what you can do and this is
a very critical moment Fabiano has to
play the move E5 and this is not an easy
move to make because after E5 take on E5
Knight takes E5 this is simply a pawn
sacrifice so you are up upon you gained
one on the queen side after the B5
sacrifice the typical Bank of sacrifice
but right now you're giving it back and
why are you giving it back so that you
gain some more speed in the position and
the Queen on H4 is not going to be very
well placed after Queen to F3 this is
not an easy idea to spot not an easy
idea to accept as white you want to hold
on to that pawn at least from a
psychological perspective so big
critical moment right now in this game
between Fabiano and mvl sure an opening
success for Fabiano we've seen how he
was playing his moves extremely quickly
but right now critical moment he needs
to find E5 if he wants to preserve his
opening advantage
thank you Christian for those updates I
must say whatever else happens in the
game between mvl and Fabi I like the
fact that the black queen is on G4
illustrating the weakness behind the
move H4 because if I was in Fabby shoes
I would love to play H4 H3 illegal
but that would be a very good move the
move E5 does not come to my mind
intuitively uh what Christian is
advocating because because they don't
like to sacrifice pawns especially the
pawns that are close to my king yeah you
know this queen is a little bit scary
you know uh the fact that Knight G you
know I could do something silly like
Knight C6 and maybe get myself into all
kinds of trouble after Knight G4 I'm not
mine is still okay because of Bishop F4
but I know what you're saying it is
still scary yeah exactly it's not
intuitively obvious to me that white
wants to play and he didn't yeah he did
play rookie one which yeah that kind of
but for Banco Gambit
players uh they're very comfortable
playing a move like Knight D7 which
unleashes their Bishop they're gonna
follow it up with Rook B8 you almost
always play Rook on the f8 to B8 in a in
a Banco then you go Rook B7 and you just
kind of wait and for white from White's
perspective
there's going to be a pressure on B2
this bishop it's not
you know like where is it gonna go is it
going to go to D2 is it going to go to
F4 is it going to go to G5 it's not that
easy rookie1 Knight D7 I think black has
and I'm a pawn Grabber I think black has
great confidence nothing what if I play
Bishop G5 okay Bishop G5 my idea is to
trap your Quinn
if it was white to play right now right
you would move I have to move my queen
queen and then Knight h2nd okay so let's
have a look rookie a queen D2 Rook b a
hello
hello oh hey goodbye please sign my
score sheet so we can get out of here so
Bishop G5 okay let's go rookie eight
Queen D2 and I guess we'll just move my
knight yeah so at least in this way I
kind of give myself a retreat to get
home uh
um or what do you think are you happy
maybe
it's hard to evaluate with the queen on
G4 I'm not sure if I can push my pawns
further on the king side exactly like
you you may be exposing your king more
than getting towards the black king
um okay Bishop G5 at least it's a very
forcing move from a Black's perspective
I don't
you know
the Banco Gambit is tough I don't want
to play the move F7 F6 but if I could
follow it up with F5
can I see like for example let's put
your Bishop on a silly Square for just a
moment and if I do follow it up with F5
maybe you go back to G5 by the way
maybe uh definitely a game that we want
to keep our eye on but I'd love to go
back to the dingler in game for a moment
because after this move Knight B1 by Yan
and by the way I think yon's got a tweak
his goals yeah if his goal is to become
2800 and you and you do it in an instant
wait a minute maybe your goal should be
to be 28.50 you know like uh raise raise
the bar yeah let's put it that way which
is up to around three right come on come
on come on yeah yeah you're not trying
hard enough Knight B1 ding is stopped
we're on move 15. yep nepo has a big
Advantage already and I think things
gonna have a very long think right now
well you can see from his body posture
is that long think has not saving him
for as he's
as he instantly seems to be aware that
wait a minute Knight D2 Knight takes B3
he clearly missed night be one idea yeah
but I feel that that shows a little bit
a non-familiarity with the position VAR
uh you don't expect the world champion
to have such a bad position after a
dozen moves absolutely yes yeah I think
yeah I don't recall seeing him play this
end game before and definitely he's not
very familiar with the position even A5
A4 idea it's I haven't seen it too often
and this maneuver Bishop C2 Bishop B3
look a little bit suspicious because
black really needed to get some
development going before doing anything
like this and that's why oftentimes we
see this move Bishop E7 coming to play
first right and uh I agree that he he
just simply missed this move Knight B1
and now uh it could be a little bit
embarrassing actually to to lose a game
like this out of the opening because
it's just it's very very hard to get any
kind of Contra play going here and he's
gonna have to sacrifice a pawn and find
a way that he can maybe get some ideas I
think he should play the move C5 and
maybe we can check some of the line see
if there is another way he can play here
but I think you need to play the smooth
C5 otherwise uh what else can you do if
you just don't do anything Knight D2
comes in will take on B3 and Rook C3 and
you're just down upon so C5 perhaps he
can maybe take in this position uh with
the Knight we can maybe take with a
knight in the previously we looked at
the move Bishop takes C5 here so Knight
D2
uh actually also now putting some
pressure maybe a rook a rookie maybe
long castle Yeah you can play This Way
Long Castle wow but uh looks looks
pretty bad Knight takes P3
Pawn takes three
now you can play here Bishop B5 or you
can play G3 here so let's say you start
out with G3 now you have an option to
put a bishop on H3 perhaps
and King B8
and here you play Knight F5 Knight is
just so nice here on F5 dude there's no
way to remove the knight from F5 is a
wonderful Outpost for him to go to you
can also you can also play the move
Bishop B5 actually here this might be
maybe a little bit more accurate to
prevent this idea of Knight A4
completely here so Bishop goes to B5
Knight F5 King E2 Rook HD1 and looks
like a winning position yesterday she is
uh it's so simple when you show it
and as we prepare for break we have a
question from our audience uh from
Jonathan Doolin on Twitter who asks yeah
sir how much do you miss competitive
chest yourself
wow I Wax and Wane I mean you know I I
love chess I love chess I love playing
chess
um the thing that stops me from playing
competitive chess is I recognize the
sacrifices that the top players have had
to make in their preparation they devote
themselves dedicate themselves in fact
to their task of the opening preparation
and I'm thinking to myself I have to
give up my life to catch up with them in
terms of preparation and we were talking
as we're doing rehearsals this morning
about Juan Lanier Dominguez and Lanier
literally spends somewhere between 10
and 20 hours each and every week simply
reviewing his files and making sure that
they're accurate and up to date not not
even you know improving them just
reviewing and everything so it takes an
enormous enormous sacrifice to become a
competitive player with these world top
players that part I don't miss if we
were just going to play Fisher random
you know come back oh yeah figure me in
you know but put me in there uh coach
I'm ready to go I'm ready to ready to
play uh competitive chess is the most
fun thing that you could possibly do in
the world now having said that I'll I'll
reverse the the question to you uh
you're coming in a first-time
broadcaster uh tell the audience
the comparisons between commentating and
playing yourself and will you come back
to competitive chat after being a
commentator yeah two very different jobs
I'll say that commentating is much less
stressful thank you yes but I do love
competing so I took a little break maybe
a little bit longer than little it was
three years okay and I've been back to
competitive chess and I don't think I'm
gonna quit again no it's it's good stuff
all right as we uh uh get ready for our
first break we asked uh the players a
feature question is uh what do you think
of the grand chest tour and what is it
about the grand chest tour that makes it
so special and makes you want to play we
ask the players
[Music]
it's the start of another grandchild
tour season what makes the grandchild
store special for you there are many
the world's best players playing so it's
not every time I get a chance to play
such a strong tournament yeah I'm very
happy to play here in Romania it's my
first time actually into this country
and it's also my first year being
full-time prior in a grocery store yeah
it's of course a very strong event and
probably one of the best and I'm looking
forward I think it's it's especially
important this year because it will also
potentially decide the Kansas
qualification and I mean besides that of
course the branches tour is also the
biggest chest to run in the world so it
has its own individual individual
importance which is really really big
but uh but I'm actually extra motivated
this year well it's my only major event
here like this area obviously I'm uh I
would probably like to play more I mean
not right now and right now I would
probably skip but yeah okay life is hard
yeah I think granchester
um when it first emerged it was the big
you know sequence of top events uh it
remains a big fixture
um and uh it's now well stronger than
ever everybody is participating yeah so
the grandchester I believe is one of a
kind event
um
since okay nowadays there are not many
close to top tournaments anyway being
organized but especially in connection
with each other it's extremely rare and
I believe the last series which was
comparable was the Grand Prix which was
an official tournament for the
qualification and uh even that is kind
of gone so to me the grandchester loan
yeah it's not my first video in the
Manchester I've been uh playing it since
since Inception in 2015. it's so in a
way it is routine but it is still a very
big challenge playing every year against
the top players of the world and you
know finding new ways and all the usual
stuff but still keeping competitive at
the highest level is a huge challenge
obviously because okay in Grand Chester
I can play against the
best players in the world and it's good
well it's a combination of the best
chess players in the world and then
playing in the best tournaments in the
world the best organized tournaments the
world also got the highest prices and
it's a season it's kind of like the NBA
people really look forward to watching
it and playing the event at the same
time for me the most important thing
about it is that it's the strongest tour
in the world maybe in the history so for
it's very obvious for me that I have to
compete in it in my best so so I could
get the best results otherwise it would
be very challenging so that's very
important
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and welcome back everyone let's take a
look look at our current standings after
round two we have three call leaders
Wesley so Richard rapper and Yanni
publishing and with one point fifty
percent in the tournament right now
current champion dinkleren Anish giri
and viel and Fabiano caruana and with
half Point hoping to catch up with the
rest of the field Duda diac and firusha
as we're in our live coverage of this
round three no results thus far but boy
we are really stunned by the game
between nepo and a dingler in because we
think that dingler in has fallen into
some opening prep and the Chinese world
champion is absolutely stuck for a move
he's had this posture for quite some
time as he's recognizing there's no easy
easy solutions for him everything that
he is looking at involves some type of a
sacrifice because this bishop on B3 is
waylaid on the Square this move Knight
D2 Knight takes B3 and Rook C3 simply
clipping upon is on White's agenda in
the meanwhile the kingside pawn
structure means this night when it gets
to that five square is going to be Lord
Master over the entire kingside and
Center so we've been looking at
Desperado right kind of sacrifices that
involve the move C5 any kind of any kind
of activity and we've been looking at
takes and Bishop takes D5 and Knight F5
and one move we didn't actually look at
but I actually found it a little bit
compelling myself was even the move
Bishop B5 is an answer to C5 this maybe
allow C4 and maybe black can at least
save the pawn
funnily enough you you're right it does
but boy at the cost of maybe this bishop
looks so
that's a pawn now that's not a bishop
yeah that is a glorified Bond uh you
know I'll probably end up playing King
D2 and I don't know moving my Rook away
maybe black has some hope that
eventually they can get to play B5 and
B4 with the B7 Pawn fair if yeah if you
could find one yeah if you can unwind
your your stuff uh dingler in in a
trouble uh no question about it uh
Wesley so another of our tournament
co-leaders he's on the white side of uh
Berlin still everything a little bit
quiet a2a3 Bishop E7 F2 F3 slow
incremental uh moves for white I think
Wesley is looking for an opportunity to
playing E5 E6 and even exchange in the
e-pawn for C point exactly uh although
the move F2 F3 in my mind Intimates that
he's still looking at night F5
possibilities to
um attack the pawn on G7 finally nope
that wasn't the game that I wanted to go
to the number one seed in the tournament
our defending grantchester champion
alireza faruja he's on the white side of
playing a tournament leader yes Richard
Rapport who's on a
the black side of Petrov when we left it
we left it around these parts we'll
throw in a couple more developing moves
I like this move Bishop C4 a lot
um a moment ago VAR was intimating that
the move Knight G5
could be one of those moves that makes
it a little bit awkward for black on the
king side Bishop back Bishop F4 and when
you're in these positions of castles on
the opposite sides uh it always seemed
to me whoever came first with the most
against the opposing King got a big Edge
the move H7 H6 wow I wouldn't have
touched my king size I was taught that
when you're under attack you do not
touch your king side pawns you and I had
the same teacher I don't know what books
you were reading but that move H7 H6
that's kind of waving a red flag uh
because if Wyatt ever gets to play F3 G4
Ng and you know the floodgates will uh
uh open uh there so I'm not sure about
that move H7 H6 VAR uh we know the
engines are cold-blooded they they just
calculate calculate either the move h7h6
is good or it's bad it's really that
simple right actually yeah so I think
it's the best move it's the best move
there you go yeah and why is it the best
move it's it's controlling the G5 score
and oftentimes that's where you we want
to put the Knight on G5 in fact after
the bishop C4 Knight G5 was a threat to
get the Knight there and put pressure on
F7 okay so and at the moment it's going
to be very difficult for white to play
the move G4 because black has it covered
the bishop and the queen so the main the
main idea is to prevent the move Knight
G5 and we can we can take a look at some
of the best moves now that uh White can
play and see what happens here so again
uh 935 is an idea here to put pressure
on F7 so H6 will simply stop that and
now it's actually one of the best moves
is to go back Bishop B3
which probably not going to happen
because we had the move Bishop C4 just
played what are the other Alternatives
here let's see here can't really play G4
it's very hard to prepare it you can
start with the move let's say Rook H E1
but then black can play even A6
controlling the B5 square at some point
maybe trying to play the move B5 as well
but really not so many options here for
white how to continue we just trade
Rooks it's just going to be an equal
position and uh normally you want to
keep one pair of Rooks to try to
organize an attack but it's very very
difficult to do that in this position
so I was also told that this bishop F4
move here was perhaps a little bit
inaccurate here in this position maybe
bishop D5 would have been a better
option here
to try to put some pressure here maybe
with ideas of Knight D4 coming up next
so I think after H6 black is absolutely
fine and I think uh reports should be
very happy with the opening outcome here
okay again to play devil's advocate for
just a moment uh therefore
um yeah you know I'm a big fan of
getting an F3 in G4 and I really need to
do it so if we were to continue after H6
with the move H5 just throwing it out
there okay and the idea is as simple as
it looks I want to go Knight H4 and on a
good day F3 G4 and Knight G6 and yeah
all in let's go black has a few
different ways you can play but the the
its engines are not afraid of H5 just
same Bishop G4 for example okay so
that's a Tempo and I can't I I gotta get
out of the pin right yeah say Rook D1 G1
just like uh going all in my next move
may be Knight H4 again either
you know just to I want a blast yes
um
here black can play for example can try
to play a little bit more actively now
with the move Knight A5 attacking the
bishop and um
and try to put an eye on C4 here
see so wow cold-blooded same idea Bishop
A2 again B5 Knight C4 even if you play
Bishop D3 then B5 will come in with the
idea to bring the Knight to C4
wow you're not geez you're not afraid of
okay Knight D4
94 Knight C4 now attacking the queen I
have to trade okay take F3 suplex
counter play seems really fast along the
along the B file suddenly right yeah I
can play Bishop F5 here or even the move
C5 actually is good black is actually
slightly better here because
you take on G4 C takes D4
let's say queen takes D4 it looks like
you're just simply up a pawn here and
now after the move Queen B5
you have Rook B8 move and now the B2
Pawn is going to be very very difficult
to defend here
so black has a really good Contra play
here wow remarkable great stuff thank
you uh Vara Italia it is is you know
it's easy to get on the wrong track
talking about getting on the wrong track
I'm looking at the game between mvl and
Fabi and I don't like what I'm seeing
for mvl I love fabi's position we just
see we the the last move was rookie one
we were looking at Knight D7
followed by Bishop G5 you are pointing
out that there was even ideas in
trapping the The Black Queen on G4 uh
there and Nasi and I was thinking okay
you know again I know that in a Banco
Gambit I have to put my Rooks on the B
file go ahead and play Rook B8 and let's
get on with business he played a
surprising move for me the move Knight
B4 which
kind of blocks up the B file and
Intimates that you have one idea The
White Square Bishop which is usually on
A6 right supporting 93 ideas yes here
without it I guess Black's idea is C4
but exactly you have to play yeah then
you're giving up D4 well Fabi said I've
kind of like the fact that you're not
getting good counter play against B2 let
me play Bishop G5 and I would have
assumed that this would have been met
more or less automatically by H7 H6 but
what on Earth is Knight H5 thank you
going very tactical so what's the idea
if y takes Bishop E7 is Knight F4
working wait a minute that was mine yeah
yeah you're stealing my vendor just a
second hold on I'm the one who's asking
questions here about capturing pawns
Massey Bishop takes Bishop takes E7 and
then you're saying yeah you don't I mean
come on I mean you just you just gave
away your whole structure if you allow
Bishop takes D6 so you you asked and
answered you're gonna have to play
Knight F4 no other choice G3 seems like
the only move looks like a good one
though as it does prevent mating one and
uh what do we do now right
so okay so mvl has been busily
calculating an exchange sacrifice maybe
with Knight D3
hard to believe frankly so rookie eight
could this be I mean then Bishop D6 with
a temple right I I mean the night got to
D3 but not at the cost of everything uh
we're having a little trouble justifying
mvl's play as we take a look at their
head to head together
wow they have played so many games boy
do they know what it is
nine wins mvl five wins and 25 draws and
this is all In classical games right I'm
sure there are a number of rapid and
Blitz is uh equal or not Superior to
that wow uh Bobby getting the edge over
the Frenchman Knight H5 uh we're not
justifying the sacrifices what is what
is mdl calculated for yeah night day
tribe it's not a very good move guys but
actually white has to play very very
precisely there there is one move in
particular he needs to find to have a
really really big Advantage objectively
I think Fabiano is almost winning here
and I will show you the key lines in
this position now okay and um so here um
Bishop takes E7 would be the best move
Knight F4 comes in now threatening mate
on G3 now you have to play G2 G3 and now
very very important is to play the move
Knight B2 D3 okay in this position
because now actually there's a very
strong threat here if you're not paying
attention to what is black trying to do
and try to take the Rook on f8 you're
actually going to get mated after this
very nice move Queen H3 exactly and now
threaten Queen G2 mate and if you
capture the Knight on F4 Knight takes F4
and queen G2 is going to be an
Unstoppable Checkmate so after this move
Knight B2 D3 the only move that gives an
advantage is Knight G5
not an obvious move stops Queen H3
though and trying to trade a quince this
is the only way to obtain an advantage
here and get rid of the queen and all
these pieces here so the main line goes
Queen takes D1
and it's not the B2 Pawn hanging uh you
actually can capture with both Rooks
here Rook 81 seems a little bit stronger
here Rook 81 and now Knight takes B2 if
you play it you Rook FEA then simply
Bishop takes D6
and Knight takes B2
a lot of things are hanging as you can
see still if you take on F4 C3 is
hanging and to hear white has two
options E5 will give an advantage as
well but the best move is Knight to B5
here
moving the Knight away uh no longer is
hanging and if Knight takes D1
Bishop takes F4 slowly position is
getting more clear now and at the end
after you move the Knight to B2 Knight
C7 gonna win one of the Rooks and it
becomes pretty clear that white should
be winning here
so this is a critical uh line here after
Knight G5
and uh you have to find this move
otherwise it's uh you don't have any
advantage and if you Retreat on D7 just
simply Bishop f8 so if Fabi finds this
move Knight G5 and I think they're going
to get to this position it's going to be
a winning position for him
wow that is out of the opening uh it's
that simple after a great deal of
distress dingler in did come up with a
move a move that we actually didn't
consider he played the move Rook on A8
to A5 no doubt he was going through his
entire list of possible
moves that he could play he eventually
came up with Rook A8 to A5 we didn't
really discuss it that much we had been
looking at C5 d d take C5 primarily
there was this move Bishop B5 maybe ding
did not like having to address that move
he played Rook eight five and
as is his wand uh Jan
pushes
the envelope uh very often he doesn't
you know take the time and reflect he's
way way ahead on the clock
he convinced himself that if my opponent
plays Rook A5 I'm gonna play Bishop B2
92. why not Knight D2 indeed uh let's
have a look at that because we thought
the whole idea was to continue and uh
hunt down and capture this bishop Knight
D2
wow I'm I'm stopping because I'm
mystified I I don't maybe simply Bishop
A2 can I you should delay The Exchange
right but
you know if you were to tell me that
this is an actual position from a game
I'd say
I get to A2
I'm just imagining it was Black's move
what would black play
five
like I'm not even sure I have to like if
I if I just you know continued with all
of the conventional moves King F2 Knight
F5 Bishop D3 at one point I am going to
play Rook C3 and yes I rather play the
other Rook to a and gift me the pawn on
B3 Rook A5 uh ding was digging deeply
into his bag of tricks to find some kind
of a move for the for his uh wrecked
position was Rook A5 a good move uh
I think the position is just really bad
the answer and Rook A5 is just a
practical idea I think the main idea we
see with this movie is he wants to play
the move C5 and after we white captures
he wants to play Rook to C5 okay and
that's a difference in some of the lines
we were looking at with Knight takes if
I were always running into the move
Bishop B5 check so at least Rook A5 now
stops that and after a long thing he
realized his position is really bad and
he's looking for some Contra play here
Bishop B2 moved play by Young it's not a
bad move at all it's the 92 was slightly
stronger but I can show you one idea I
think where it will make it maybe a
little bit clear why he played the move
Bishop E2 first here so let's take a
look here so he started off with the
bishop E2 not a bad move here but what
he's trying to do now after the move C5
yeah D takes C5 and the main idea of
this Rook A5 is just to take back with
the rook and here I think what he's
trying to do is the difference between
92 and Bishop he can just simply play
King F2 here and now he's connecting his
Rooks and you see The Rook on h8 is
still long very far away from coming
into the game here now the Rooks are
connected and 92 move will be played
next and I think this is the main idea
why I played Bishop E2 and now if Knight
B6 played for example Knight D2
putting pressure on the bishop and also
the threatening now to capture on C5
Bishop C5 and just simply play Rook C1
King is very well placed on F2 is also
protecting the the weak E3 pawn and here
black has some options Bishop C4 for
example or Bishop C2 but in in both
cases it's a it's a two pound Advantage
for Whitehead if you play Bishop C2
Knight D to F3 now getting ready to put
the Knight on D4 it's going to be an
excellent Outpost uh there and Bishop B3
for example then Knight will go to D4
and you're not winning material
immediately but as we can see the Knight
on D4 this other night will come to F5
Bishop B5 is another idea here white has
a very clear Advantage here and very
good winning chances I think for Nepal
no question about it I agree
wholeheartedly thank you uh VAR a game
that kind of slipped away from us is a
must win game we feel between Duda and
diac both of those players are currently
at -1 trying to get back into the game
and a very very sharp position from the
opening unfolded this was the rosalima
with the move a7a6 we got to this
position B7 B5 Black's play looks a
little bit artificial to my eyes and
after Bishop G5 Bishop B7 Queen D2 C5 D5
like as a good chess coach you know you
sit back and say look look at my student
he's taking over the center he has these
powerful Pawns in the middle of the
board he's connected his Rooks you know
white has followed all of the scripture
if you will uh position is looking great
except uh deox says well before I go
down you know without a shout uh let me
at least play the move Knight D7 so that
you can't just go Bishop H6 and
routinely uh Checkmate me because any
Bishop H6 is going to be met by
knightsey Ford a tickle to the queen and
to the pawn on B2 now here was my
question for you
you like the initiative right I do but
you're a Material Girl
would you play the move b2b3 is white
potentially sacrificing The Exchange
knowing that when you do sacrifice
exchange you've got this great dark
Square to play for watch would you play
B3 I would but I have more options in
this position I really like simply Rook
a to D1 it looks ad1 lights position
just looks so beautiful all my pieces
are perfectly placed right very very
harmonious to be sure the question was
more like you're not intimidated by the
night on scene play B3 later right okay
so you think that uh just simply Rook D1
and a shoeling B3 threatening D6 at some
point with the Rook on D1 it's it's
looking great for white it certainly is
it it it it feels uh like a comfortable
Edge for sure so we're seeing a lot of
you know really nice uh positions we
think that
three games or a white has an advantage
huge uh and again the dingler in game
the the biggest one alireza uh that
whole uh line where you know like I just
felt so frustrated I was playing trying
to go H5 Knight H4 G4 and VAR is
laughing at me and he's going okay I'll
just go Knight E5 V5 I'll stick my
knight on C4 what happened instead uh
farouja after the move H7 H6 said okay
I'm gonna play Rook H1 to G1 maybe
playing for Knight H2 even though this
looks really soft
but if I do get in G4 yeah yeah well
Knight will come back exactly yeah uh
Bishop to G4 that pin and that pin is
pretty awkward so uh farusha got out of
the bin with a move Rook D1 and again
you know it it's slow balling but if he
does get in Knight H2 if he does get an
F3 and G4 he will have the initiative
and it's up to Black what that that move
Knight A5 and B5 really kind of threw me
off I wasn't expecting yeah that counter
play coming from the side of the board
yeah as it did
um early take of this position is white
have the advantages that the other
players are enjoying I think that in
this position if Richard doesn't play
too passively and he does start his
counter play on The Queen side he will
be completely fine and how should he do
that maybe 985 985 right away yeah and
again following it up with maybe five
nights at four intriguing wow okay and
finally Wesley so versus Anish Gary
again is very slow uh Berlin ending
uh well just a second we don't have G5
on the board yeah that got a okay uh I
was asking the question is if E5 E6 an
idea for white well maybe Anish thought
it was he played G5 and I gotta say
that's a bold move I I mean you're kind
of you don't get to take your moves back
there on the and the move G5 gives up
control over the F5 Square it looks like
Black's playing for an attack on the G
file but it might backfire because it is
also weakened in Black's King side very
much so yeah okay so it I'll ask the
most obvious question if I go King F2 do
you think uh Anish is really going to go
for G4 maybe he should play F6 first
because if he gets rid of the E Pawn yes
and opens up his second Bishop then G4
looks more attractive to me okay after
that
but
Black's King kind of is is stuck on the
e-file as well right maybe I can fake
castle with King yeah yeah yeah yeah
do the two-step Shuffle and get out of
Dodge uh very nice let's see they're
Head to Head uh against one another
Wesley cell versus Anish Gary I would
have counted on the 20 draws I didn't
see this many victories and I didn't see
such an evil outcome between three and
three wow they match up well together I
don't they okay and uh VAR what has
caught your attention uh there are a
couple of interesting uh games here we
can maybe go through at the moment the
G5 definitely looks a little bit risky
in this one and uh by Anish but I think
uh he knows the ideas and this Rook G8
is a good move it not only protects the
pawn on G5 it also threatening this move
G4 which we're gonna see here for
example in the line against King F2 here
if you do this move then G4 actually is
a very possible move to play here F6 is
also a fine move here as Nazi mentioned
F6 is absolutely fine too but you do
have the smooth G4 here try to follow it
up with the idea of Rook G8 and G4 and
if you take care just simply takes on G4
now creating some control play on F3 and
it's it's just com all zeros here like
for example Knight F5 GTX F3 and the
main idea we see here every time you
play Knight F5 in this position black
has this move Bishop to E6 to try to get
rid of the Knight right and after we
take only seven you can play Rook D1 for
example Rook takes D1 and King E7 and
it's just completely equal positioning
very important that you have the G5
Square covered otherwise after Bishop G5
Rook d8 you you could be in a really
serious trouble here there's a bishop C5
uh check here by just kng8 my spidey
sense is tingling why can't I take that
pawn on A7 you can't take but then that
will allow that will allow the move
Bishop H3 and now I would like to play
the move Rook G2 next so creating
creating my own Contra play and if you
play the move Rook G1 we know that this
end game is yeah that's just going to be
a draw after the exchange of the Rooks
here but let's take a look at another
game here
um in a report game that we were looking
at here actually block has two
interesting ways to play here he can
just uh play the move rookie looks like
that's what he's doing just exchanging
or he could have played the plan that we
mentioned earlier with the Knight A5 and
B5 that might have been a little bit
more ambitious way to play because now I
think once the Rooks come off the board
most likely the players will consolidate
and I think this game is probably going
to head towards the draw but we can take
a look at the Knight A5 move actually
without trading the Rooks here so after
the move Rook de1 here if Richard wanted
to play more ambitiously I think Knight
A5 is a really good move it's a top move
recommended by engine now attacking the
bishop and now you really have to figure
out where to put the bishop you can go
on A2 or on D3 perhaps if you go to A2
the whole idea is very simple B5 now you
want to put the Knight on C4 to Simply
blockade the bishop and essentially
Force the move Bishop takes C4 after
which black will have the pair of the
Bishops so and if you play the move
Knight H2 here trying to attack the
bishop
white can't even play the move Bishop E6
trading the Bishops and after again we
have this C4 Square for our Knight Rook
takes E6 Queen takes E6 and King B1 is
one of the options Knight C4 and black
is actually very slightly better in this
position so I think this was another
good alternative how black could
continue to play but the way he played
Rook takes C1 rookie 8 it's it's
absolutely fine for black and uh I think
uh very close to equality the position
yeah very frustrating for Ali Reza as is
I mean it was clear that with the move
Rook G1 he was going for this uh King
side opening expansion you know get the
flank attack and it's just not
getting it done and he's he's
not able yeah push push an attack
um Fabi I'm a player after my own heart
captured the pawn he just said okay I
don't trust the attack let me play
Bishop takes E7 which of course is
devastating for a white for Black's Pawn
structure you take the bass Pawn you
know it's not just ace Paul yeah and
everything else will fall and we saw a
line by VAR explaining to us that Knight
F4 threatening made on G2
G3 Knight B4 to D3 and this is
doubtlessly what attracted mvl this
whole sequence beginning with Queen G4
Knight before in his mind he saw this
position he said this is great go ahead
and take my Rook so that I can mate you
Queen H3 takes Knight takes and there's
my Checkmate and please sign my score
sheet but as far mentioned I just have
to stop you from playing Queen H3 at the
moment I'm two pawns up and trading
Queens really is a great way of stopping
the attack Knight G5 Queen takes D1 you
I think in a funny kind of way well I
can recapture with everything here you
know the night The Rook the other Rook
whatever Rook you want to take with uh
Knight takes Rook takes kisses are
hanging and this guy is hanging this guy
is hanging uh this guy f8 is hanging D6
is hanging and again yeah well B2 why
does two pawns up but
it's worse in the sense that you're not
gonna you're structure it's it's failing
and this is this is all going in fobby's
Direction regardless of whether you you
go for Knight takes E1 or Knight takes
B2 you cannot uh
restore the damage that you've already
created and Bishop takes E7 on the board
and now mvl is really
you know scrunching into the position
and maybe coming to the realization
that Knight G5 is going to answer all of
White's prayers
listen I think Christian and Darius
should be happy because they picked Fabi
over my pick mvl
yes I would say so uh yeah it's not
looking for good for a dingler in but
okay Rook A5 Bishop E2 played very very
quickly C5 Knight F5 now we talked about
how great this Knight is and you look
across the board and say what are your
pieces doing and ding learns that I have
to agree my pieces have got to get some
work he played the move Knight B6 which
I like I mean it it shows that he's
ready to fight for squares you know with
you Bishop C4 and or Knight C4 let's get
going and I'm assuming Knight D2 is what
uh nepo has prepared yeah I think Buck
will have to play C4 okay uh
but in the sort of way uh that shuts
down a lot of things but not here yeah
because before when we were looking at
C4 your Bishop was on B5 and Knight was
on C3 correct here I think black will
have much easier time playing B5 before
well the Knight will have to move from
B6
yeah right so
you know you're right in the sense that
if you move your knight you get to play
B5 you get to play B4 three four moves
away you've
I'll survive well you've got your
counter play you're kind of happy right
but at a certain moment you know bad
things are going to happen uh Najee
let's let's show you what what are those
bad things that could happen let's go
King F2 Knight to seven let's say you go
Knight D7 let's say I go Bishop H5
let's say I go rookie one oh no oh yes
oh no yes and uh essentially the king is
still in the center of the board right I
mean there are some some issues now you
Rook on A5 I I you know applause
applause applause but I think it's more
about the King on E8 so you can't be so
self-centered self-concentrating that
it's all about B5 B4 plans
um so maybe black has to play Knight C8
and Knight D6 ah I like that to at least
challenge me a little bit right so
Knight D2 did we say C4 yes okay let's
say king of
now when I played the moon Bishop H5 I
was kind of flippant because I wasn't
sure where the G4 was the best square or
F3 wasn't but I'm pretty sure I want my
Rook on E1 in all cases and now maybe
you want to improve as well Knight D6 I
have to okay let's do it nine to D6 and
here we go uh again this bishop is a
little bit offsides I don't see how I
can exploit it right away
okay uh what can I say Bishop to G4 I
will have one
is 94 an option that might be two you
know it's funny because we remember
there was earlier where where VAR was
pointing out he liked to play G3 and
Bishop G2 and round up the pawn maybe I
can do a Roundup in a different kind of
way Knight G3 and Bishop F5 I don't know
94 might not work so then let's take a
look at Knight takes F5 and just develop
in my Bishop say
here
so E4 is coming and my King's in trouble
so correct that's what I'm playing for
that's what I've uh prepared for that so
that's why Bishop D6 okay
um I don't like giving up my phone on F4
should I play King F3 or king or G3 I'm
not sure let's play one of the two
can I Castle
how dare you don't remember if the king
moved or not
uh we're having fun analyzing whether or
not black should play the move C five C
four of our but in certain way when you
play the move C4 is black
well you you shut down the position so
you're giving white a free hand in the
center and on the king side should black
be playing for C5 C4
I think uh yeah in this line after 92
yes C4 is going to be fine okay but I
think white wants to keep the Knight on
B1 and actually put it on C3 okay this
is in most of the lines I was checking
when you guys were analyzing actually
sure he wants to play for example even
King F2 here and then when C4 comes
Knight will go to C3 so I can show you a
few lines here please so let's say in
this position you can play King F2 which
is the top move and if you play the move
let's say C4 anyway okay now Bishop
comes to F3 or you can start with Knight
C3 doesn't really matter that much now
you want to play Bishop F3 and put
pressure on D5 so this is actually a
really really strong the best way to
continue for black here is perhaps
Knight A8 wow which is not an easy move
to find but then Bishop F3 comes in
putting pressure on D5 Knight C7 would
be the only move and again now white can
just play E4 is a very big Advantage but
also you can start out with the move G4
support and just as you mentioned in
earlier line rookie one comes in E4 and
it's a really really big Advantage here
you don't even have to play 40 40 meter
you can even play H4 maybe even some G5
ideas so really unpleasant position for
black and uh really good winning chances
here for nepo thank you VAR indeed that
would be the case uh you can see that
nepo is not Blitzen like he likes to do
now he's taking his time yeah and uh as
you know as a competitor at least you go
into the playing Hall you get wanded you
know you check you for fair play we're
gonna do the same
for fair commentary why because uh White
is played exactly your mood
no V3 I refer of course to the game
between Duda and dioc because it was in
this position I was asking you uh would
you like would you be willing to play
the move B3 and uh sacrifice The
Exchange you said you would but that
you'd like an additional option of
playing Rook D1 because you didn't have
the sacrifice exchange and then after
moves like Knight C4 Queen C1 you were
also mentioning that D6
it's something that you're happy about
and it turned out to be uh do this
Choice as well and that's why you're
going to get the wand and make sure
everything is you know keep it keep it
friendly right I'm ready well done well
done that's it and it does look to my
eyes as well uh that White's position is
very very harmonious and we enjoy your
questions and stumping uh the resident
experts here and we've got a social
media question bring it from David
Franklin from YouTube and the question
is NEPA suffers from reverse time
travels he plays too fast I have the
same problem at a much lower school
level any advice
well uh first of all the fact the fact
that you're not in real time trouble but
reverse time trouble is actually uh
something very good and secondly this
idea that uh it's something very very
easy for you to cure in that
enjoy the game enjoy the position and uh
you see a good move
take your time and as Michael Tall said
you see a good move think for a moment
maybe you find a better one yeah
uh so for me I think that uh that's
something that you just naturally grow
into as you start to realize that chess
is a really rich uh game and you know
that there are a lot of really good
moves in a position just get used to it
uh are you a time trouble person
yourself do you avoid time trouble you
like being ahead on the clock
I used to be just like Nepal extremely
fast player right I would finish my
games with more time than I started with
wow okay so you were a visiona and uh
type speeds yes but then my coach uh
taught me this simple trick I was still
uh pretty young then sit on your head
sit on your hands right and don't make a
move until you spend at least five ten
minutes on each move oh and then I
learned with that technique that more
time I spend on each move more ideas I
find better I understand the position
okay and better I end up playing
so after that I slowed down so now I
have another problem I do get into that
right exactly I think that that happens
far uh jump in here what's been your
experience should I say coach what's
been your experience yeah no most of my
career I actually get into time travel
and a lot of the tournaments even when I
do really well I go through some uh
tough time travel games and uh being
practical and managing your clock is
very important and I think it's it's
easier to perhaps slow down and but it's
very hard to change when you've been
let's say time travel addict for many
many years it's very hard to change that
I find that but I think if you just
figure out a way to control yourself and
spend a little bit more time I think uh
there is a way to to fix that and it
will improve the game and of course as
Nazi mentioned you will find some more
ideas after spending time in a
particular position uh VAR the game that
you have behind issues there I really
like the harmonious position I like do
disposition I just I I find it very
harmonious
is it advantage or
do the engines say oh it's wonderful
black is fine I mean these groom felt
positions are are not difficult
whatsoever it's a very big Advantage
actually it is I really like this
position it's it's uh uh not completely
winning but like very close to actually
being almost a winning position here wow
and uh here yeah you have the control of
the centers uh you have all your pieces
are very well developed and Consolidated
and all you need to do is actually just
try to figure out a way to exchange the
Bishops and once you do that then you
have really good attacking chances here
so let's take a look at some of the
lines now that can happen after the move
Rook C8 for example so here you can you
have two options here you can play
Bishop H6 but also you can play the
restricting move which I really like
this move B3 here okay because you want
to prevent this move Knight C4 from
happening and if you play let's say the
move C4 for example then actually white
can even play just take a time and play
the move before just to blockade that
side of the board and then next follow
it up with the bishop H6 idea and this
will be a nice Advantage here for white
okay if you uh try for some other play
here you really need to play the move E6
here to try to justify putting the
bishop on B7 to open up the diagonal but
it's very hard here so let's say you
play rookie eight
and why can even continue here in this
position just to play when H4 H5 here to
create some weaknesses so very hard
let's let's look take a look let's say
you play H4 here now you're threatening
H5 and if you play B4 Knight will
actually will go to E2 and here you have
an option to put a knight on a G3 and
again continue with H5 and you'll have a
lot of pieces around the black Kink here
and as you can see you only have one
Bishop here defending so this is
actually a big Advantage as well or if
you want to go uh more directly here
after the move Rook C8 you actually can
play the move Bishop H6 here that's the
move that I like the most just get rid
of that good Bishop yeah and now we have
to check this line Knight C4 which is
critical but now this is actually really
bad because you have Queen C1 right you
know it's Knight C4 comes in with the
tempo but sometimes this kind of moves
don't do much and after that you're
going to get actually kicked by B3 and
here if you take on H6 Queen take H6 and
of course if you pick up the pawn on B2
you're gonna get checkmated after the
move Knight G5 with the queen H7 idea so
that's why you cannot take on B2 here
and
you you're gonna need to do something
against the move Knight G5 here for
example F6
here and here actually just B3 and
you'll have to move the Knight again and
there are some weaknesses around the
king the best movie here is 95 but I
think this doesn't look that good here
because now
there are Pawn weaknesses again the
bishop is actually really really bad on
B7 and white will have a really big
Advantage here no I love this for uh for
for white for Duda for sure I like to
turn our attention to
the return World Chess Championship 2023
a game between nepo and Ding and I was
looking at the the the current position
and I said you know I got it wrong
because somehow black got two moves
black was two moves and I was sort of
like what did white do why didn't white
play King F2 and rookie one or King F2
and Bishop F3 it was a strange sequence
so from the beginning we were kind of
looking from white to play a move like I
don't know King F2 and against C4 we
would go Knight C3 that was that so uh
King F2 seemed like the
most reasonable followed by rookie one
uh no nepo said Knight D2
C4 my move right Knight B1 so he lost
two Tempe but I feel like was going to
place it for anyways yes exactly so it
it feels like nepo lost to Tempe where
and uh that whole idea of B5 I think it
was like vars idea uh
I said 98 but I remember Varsity Knight
A8 988 and go B5 B4 still don't know why
now it's good on A8 but it looked better
on
D6 you know like that it did on the head
so okay uh I don't know this loss of two
Tempe isn't inspiring uh far I don't
think that nepo uh pressed his advantage
in the best way no I think he completely
misplayed the position in fact yeah he
lost most of his Advantage here no
really it's actually maybe he's a little
bit better here at the time that he
wasted is just uh you know to Tempe and
the point guys that we play 98 97 is
because we want to have that D5 Pawn uh
protected and get ready to play B5
before at some point I like this Knight
on C7 just because the main problem in
this position we have this D5 pawn and
we want to make sure we have it
protected so we can check now some of
this line but definitely losing two
Tempest was not good here and I think
ding is getting some serious chances to
get back into the game here let's take a
look what what are the best moves now in
this position so after Knight B1 he
really needs to play the this move uh
Knight A8 here to bring the Knight to C7
to protect uh dd5 Pawn there is no other
good way to do that and perhaps maybe a
Nepal missed that idea that this Knight
can go to system because everything else
still white is much better here so let's
take a look Knight A8 so he can start
with Bishop F3 okay Knight to C7
and here if you play the move Knight C3
that's the most obvious move yeah and
now black is actually gaining a really
strong counter player with B5 in fact
black is actually slightly better now
wow because if you take on D5 right
takes it takes four and despite having
no development here this B form of comes
really strong and now we see the point
of this move Rook A5 very deep idea and
Rook is excellently placed here and now
we have the bishop hanging A3 is hanging
so this actually a very very nice
Advantage for black now so this Knight
C3 move would be a mistake actually here
after B5 black would be even better so
he needs to start out with the move King
F2 first okay to connect the Rooks and
black will continue here two different
ways to continue can play King d8 here
move the king away from the e-file or
just continue with B5 here right so now
again if you play 93 before it's gonna
come next and as soon as you play the
move B5 the next move is you want to
play B4 and try to create counter play
and I think black is actually doing fine
here and uh he's got some good country
play with this B5 before well if you
just continue that uh line that you the
the very position so we play E4
said in order to open up the the center
if you will I will continue with before
and we continue Knight
F5 drops back I want to go after the C4
plus yeah this is this is the best way
to continue but now
um
there is there is a rook A7 move here
actually
that I'm trying to understand uh the the
point is maybe to go Knight B5 at some
point so let's let's take a look at the
the more obvious line let's say take on
A3 I'll recapture the Knight tonight on
B1 is doing nothing back in the game
perhaps that was the reason why maybe
Rook A7 is a Little Bit Stronger move
here so now Bishop takes A3 the pawn
takes A3 it's amazing that Bishop on B3
that's been stuck is actually uh playing
a role and by the way ding did find
Knight A8 yeah the 88 is on the board
here actually white is a little bit
better here so I think perhaps I need to
play this move uh Rook A7 here and keep
the pawn uh keep the pawn on B4 here so
Rook A7 yes not an intuitively obvious
move I must say Rook A7 and also yeah so
there's some C3 ideas now coming up too
yeah
and uh I'm familiar with this Pond
breakthroughs yeah it's it's a pretty
crazy position perhaps white is still a
little bit better but uh ding is kind of
crawling back into the game and I think
uh he's getting some chances now okay uh
turning our attention to our defending
champion
they have the L we think mvl is somehow
really on the back foot kind of got us
it got caught there in uh some tactics
that didn't work out right he did not
play Knight b2d3 with the queen H3 idea
he played rookie 8 instead because of
this Knight G5 where it seemed to be
just simply a dead end so here he is
he's sitting there going oh my gosh my
Rook is under attack my knight is under
attack I'm being facing off with Knight
G5 but the first moves we rejected we
rejected Rook E8 because we thought well
Bishop takes D6 just Scoops up uh the
whole structure and puts pressure on the
night well guess what he did play rookie
eight and
I don't mind if I do I'll uh I'll take
one Pawn can I have another Bishop takes
D6 on the board and mvl is going to be
scram gambling to find any kind of
compensation here can he be thinking of
using this Knight
negative D3 I don't know do you be
hoping to take on B2
well I'm just seeing I'm just seeing
Devastation I'm I'm three pawns down my
knight on F4 is hanging it's three
already wow right yeah well I took one
on the queen side E7 D6 so yeah yes so
it's a knight D3 yes white has to play
Rook E3 yes and then at least I can pick
up one Pawn maybe on B2 or is mine
getting trapped there I do admire your
you know last great Act of defiance but
it's not enough it's not enough Knight
takes B2 uh Queen E2 by the way it's not
like white has bad development right
it's like like the pieces are in the
center E4 E5 might just shut down
everything
um material ahead
um
again the quote Roman jinji Ashville it
just feels like I've got material and
the compensation uh I don't I it's not
looking good for mvl uh we're doing our
desperate best to save the Frenchman but
I don't think
it we can what about uvar no you guys
are absolutely right the MBL position is
actually completely lost it's almost
plus five now for Fabi and plus five
yeah yes he's up he is up three pounds
you know the best case scenario in wheel
maybe can win one Pawn back and then
still gonna be down a couple of Pawns
here I will show you uh the the way that
Fabi can just simply uh simplify the
position couple of accurate moves and I
think he's just gonna be able to win
this game so here as you mentioned the
best movie is rookie three yeah you
really want to get rid of the Knight on
D3 sure and now Knight takes B2 I think
is necessary
okay and here Queen B3 comes in Queen B3
I want Queen E2 but putting pressure now
uh on B2 and also you're covering the C4
Square okay so there are there are two
options here you need to put one of the
knights on D3 we can look at both here
so if you bring the knight from D2 to D3
here here I have a few options I can
play the move E5 which is very good but
I actually can take the third Pawn now
Bishop takes you one because now these
Knights are now awkward they're
defending but if you take on C5 I have
Queen takes B4 so and if you play Bishop
C3
I can play Queen takes C3
Rook ac8
now you're pinning a
uh my Bishop I have a two options here I
can play Rook takes D3 like I can do
Rook takes Z3 Knight takes D3 Queen D3
Rook C5 that's three pounds yeah and
play the move here actually uh D6 is
very nice D6 or E5 yeah three pawns for
the exchange and if you take Queen takes
C4 I have dc7 and deflecting the rook
and winning but this is not even the
best way how a white can continue here
wow he can actually sacrifice the queen
here for a even bigger Advantage here so
you can play Bishop takes B4 here
Rook takes C3 and after Bishop takes C3
now there are no any no attack anymore
here and the bishop is very strong on C3
and uh you have uh rook and a knight and
three pass three pounds A5 A6 is coming
up so this is actually also completely
winning here so this is if he plays the
knight uh two to D3 but let's take a
look in this position if he plays uh
Knight
before 2d3 this is another alternative
in this case the best move here is just
simply to
shut down this bishop here just maybe
even give up on Palm but simply locate
this bishop so there is uh not really
any good way to continue here
um you can play C4 perhaps attacking the
queen and both Queen B5 or queen C2 will
give white a winning Advantage here it
just looks terrible the knights are not
even that well placed what is the Knight
on B2 doing uh no it looks like Fabi is
actually good prep is uh gifting him
at the point I want to put it like that
just turning to the game of dioc for a
moment because I did like this move
Bishop H6 Duda followed up didn't feel
that even b2b3 was necessary now that
the Rooks were harmoniously centralized
on the D and the E file that was a
player I felt it was in chess history
the world champion Vasily Smith who
didn't get the full credit he was in the
shadow of Michael bodvinick too much in
my uh view he uh Smith had a beautiful
harmonious style and I liked his play
very very very much and you know moves
like Bishop H6 he was like this natural
come very very easy to him dingler and
nepo Knight A8 and uh though they'll be
exploring that yeah he was back in the
game and they'll be exploring those uh
positions that we had been looking at
Ian looks too happy on the camera
and by the way uh there was this moment
where dingler in not this moment it was
this like half hour like ah yeah I have
a horrible position now we see the kind
of the reverse body posture what's the
what's the times on the clocks because
ding really was eating a lot of time I
think that was catching ketchup so I
think is down to 27 minutes 28 but nepos
38 so
so okay
yeah so uh Knight A8 and move that uh
bringing ding back into the game as vars
made very clear put the Knight on C7
very important support the pawn on B5 D5
pardon me as well as supporting uh the
pawn on B5 tonight on both the D7 and
the B6 squares wasn't doing so much on
C7 it looks to be much more uh I found
its calling yeah right I mean everybody
needs their role right and Ali Riza
versus Richard Rapport whoa what has
going on here so when we left it we saw
this move Rook E8 and change change I
think it's pretty equal it looks but
wait a minute let's move Queen B5 said
alert alert
C4
okay well Richard's being annoying this
is heading to a queen exchange probably
Queen C2 yeah I don't like this uh this
queen uh hanging out and were you
thinking this type of a thing
that could potentially be a draw or you
were thinking that any Queen trade was
probably
is Richard going to win a second bishop
and game
well uh hey you got to push your luck
Right Wesley so versus Anish Gary uh
this was with this whole uh G5 and Rook
G8 and there was no King F2 G4 he went
Knight F5 and
I find that interesting he didn't play
Bishop E6 and end up uh losing the pawn
on A7 instead I find this intriguing
that he said hey I like my fawn on A7
I'm gonna protect it played them of b7v6
King F2 Bishop E6 and in this way he's
saying go ahead and take if you want but
I kind of like my knight on F5
imagine I was to just play G4 yeah that
looks really nice yeah keep it cemented
the Knight on F5 uh I don't think black
can ever touched that night yeah no this
would be a dream I think this is
certainly something that black has to
avoid you may want to trade H pawns if
you're in Black I guess
it comes down to this move Rook to D5
right because if I have to trade well
okay then I'm not I'm not that unhappy
um
does Wesley have a little something
something here or we just grasping its
raws uh VAR I think Wesley has some
Advantage here I think anisha's last
movie should be sick was slight
inaccuracy okay and I will show you the
reason why and so in this position this
F5 score is very very important here and
what Anish had to do here after move
King F2 he could have played this move
H4 first
so when he plays the more Bishop E6 next
for example if we just play a rook ac1
Bishop E6 you no longer have to move G4
because then we can take on G3 right so
this is actually a very important in
this position yes and if you play Knight
to E7 you can play
King takes E7 Rook d8 King d8 let's say
Rook D1 check you will play uh King C8
here or King G8 it's it's not easy to it
seems like this G5 Pawn is really weak
but you don't have a really good way
here that you can attack this Pawn again
in this position so I will keep my Rook
on G8 and just try to defend this this
just shows about equal position here but
after the move Bishop E6 now like in the
game after G4 now white has a very nice
Advantage here because you can never
take on F5 as you mentioned right and
it's going to be very annoying uh to
defend this because you always have to
watch out for the Knight takes E7 and
also Bishop takes G5 ideas so the Knight
on F5 is very well placed here and I
think now Anish is uh definitely a
slightly worse and he's gonna be
uncomfortable defending this position
but it was that question uh VAR of Rook
D5 because I Rook D5 through 55 here
yeah that that moved through me off
because if I have to play Rook takes D5
C6 takes D5 black is
okay uh perhaps I can actually play like
this take only five first okay C takes
D5 right
and
I can also play here B4 just to try to
play positionally try to prevent the C5
move and uh White is a little bit better
here after B4 just because the Knight on
yeah five is strong also even this
position after capturing on uh E7 King
takes E7 again you play the move B4
and here it's a little bit different
than in the previous time because you
have some ideas like C3 A4 A5 you can
generate some Contra play on a file here
and activate your Rook on a seven trunk
and The Rook is going to be tied up to
the defense of the G5 Pawn so let's say
you take on
G4 H takes G4 and now I have The Rook H1
option as well so
uh this could be unpleasant here looks
like black has to play some accurate
moves like Bishop D7 here perhaps and uh
trying to get some Contra play with the
move King E6 to put pressure here chess
can be confounding when I find the move
Rook D5 was proud of myself for
undoubling my bonds once my pawns were
undoubled I was worse like what you know
A4 A5 and get the Rook to the seventh
rank so uh Wesley so one of our
tournament co-leaders seems to be
enjoying a position against Anish Gary
and their head to head was as even as it
could possibly be wow I'm really
impressed by that uh again uh well I I
love our viewers questions you know I
feel like I I I want to encourage people
to put us to the test and ask whatever
you would like Bobby against MPL we do
have on the board the very United States
we're looking at so if Fabi plays Queen
B3 it's pretty much over and why did we
reject Queen E2 because somehow I found
Queen E2 somehow logical sorry Bishop
takes C3 and Knight A4
picking up another Pawn E2 Bishop takes
C3
Rook takes E3 I saw Rook takes E4 Queen
take to and I stopped I didn't consider
this hopefully Knight takes A4
may I
Rook A3 I assume Rook takes E4
yes guess so oh you have Knight C3 oh
now we understand why the computer like
Queen V3 I didn't see Knight C3
apologies for that okay so yes not Queen
E2 but Queen B3 and this is where we
were looking at 93 or 93 and either
either play why it has Bishop C5 Bishop
C5 or even E5 and shut things down and
Fabi for Choice
um yeah this is that I mean if you look
at the position just visually this is a
um benko gone wrong yes because White
Center is just fantastic and you know
the coordination of the night on takes
B2 Knight on B2 makes no sense and queen
B3
one of the things both of these two uh
warriors uh I really admire them is
their calculation
their calculation is unbelievable uh
they just
really penetrate deeply and I'm not
talking like three five moves I'm
talking seven eight twelve moves and
very complicated positions and very
complicated positions and you know I've
been here during the sinkfield cup and
you know we've had some after party and
uh where you know they just they just
analyze oh I wanted to play this and
it's like
and you go what you know you calculated
this whole thing yeah well you were
spending so long and I was walking
around and I was thinking about this and
that's what they do both of these guys
they calculate
incredibly well and it it really is
impressive at certain times I think to
myself I really need to get a video
camera you know I'd see and we have what
we think is a repetition going on in the
game uh between Richie and Ali Reza and
by the way they did get to Bishop ending
yeah
and uh I just agree to it yeah first
result Queen B3 there was a queen trade
and
yeah
players then found a way of repeating
the position and our first result
Petrov holds yeah but also comfortably I
mean again one E2 E4 players are not
rejoicing because they're not getting
anything against E4 I mean the Berlin
put
a very big question mark over E4
Petrov is doing it as well coach when
you sit there and you get into our uh uh
uh
training camps as we see our first
result producer report just made a draw
and somebody says what are we going to
do against the Russian defense
what can you tell them yeah it's
definitely not easy to find any
advantage against this opening Yasser
even with the top engines the analyze
black is actually good in most of the uh
the lines and all you need to do is try
to find the best you can do is find some
new ideas and try to put a little bit of
pressure on the opponent just an idea
maybe for one game to try to put some
problems for the opponent to solve but
all the lines black is doing fine and
very hard to get anything like even 0.5
or something will be huge to accomplish
in the petrol of Defense
he gets but that just really is very
very sad for one E2 E4 players what I'm
hearing instead I should start playing
petrol yes yes
join a very very very long line of
illustrious world champions who over the
years have championed uh
the Russian defense and uh yeah we're
seeing that uh black I gotta tell you
this was a comfortable hole for Richie
very very easy very easy yeah he didn't
he didn't seem to be under any
particular pressure whatsoever whereas
when you look at the game of Wesley so
for example Wesley's got a little bit
something something going on
nepo had something for sure that that
whole Knight D2 Knight B1 losing to
Tempe essentially you could have the
same position he has on the board right
now with maybe the King on F2
yeah and that would be making all the
difference in the world fabi's got a
fabulous position he's coming out of the
opening with extra pawns and yeah
great
room you know
a coordination of his pieces two dies
also and do that there's a lot of
pressure and has a wonderful position I
think
so he did everything he wanted and even
got it the icing on the cake as well he
got to trade the dark Square Bishop the
dark Square Bishop on G7 was Black's
best piece stop
so you just eliminated that that's only
good piece yeah exactly then you played
the move b2b3 which restrains this night
the night's not jumping to C4 D6
and you've maintained your Central Pawn
Duo
this is the type of position where you
better start thinking in terms of you
know forcing moves I don't care whether
they're C4 I don't care whether the rook
d8 and E6 because if you give white the
time he needs he might just slowly page
Harry the H Pawn but let's jump to a
Bucharest as Christian is with our top
seed in the tournament
thank you Yasser alireza first of all
welcome to the show welcome back to
Romania how do you feel up to this point
about this tournament about your
performance yeah
um obviously disappointed with how it's
going for now
um I think I guess Wesley was the
decisive guy of course and it was a very
complicated game and I missed G5 so and
after that was all down here so
um but yeah now against Anish the second
game I'm happy with the game I played
with black
and today was nothing special you even
perhaps got a slight advantage against
arnish so definitely it was moving along
the right way yeah yeah exactly but I
didn't want to over push again like I
did against Wesley so
um for now I just I'm happy with how I'm
playing but the result is not so big
would you say that in classical chess
especially since you haven't played in a
very very long time did you feel a bit
Rusty as we were entering this yeah for
sure like I didn't play for my last
event was thinking in September yes
I was out of classical game and
I think I have to come back slowly
slowly sir and it's um best opportunity
in Romania to do that and it's almost
reminiscent of last year you started off
slowly in Romania but after that you
picked up uh steam in the other events
as well and it did amazing you ended up
winning the grandchild Story You're the
defending Champion Now take us through
today's game against Richie who we know
is a very intriguing player but he
surprised you at all with the Petrov
yeah of course he's he plays everything
so it's like impossible to prepare
against him it's really amazing and I
expected French French okay yeah because
he's still and of course I expected his
Sicilian these four nights
puts with uh yeah no no 96 96 or he's
expert of this minor 696 yeah yeah 966
he's he was playing it in candidates
most of all the time so yeah yeah and
but okay he also plays Petra but I
didn't have time to check
also and he planned he played Petrov I
wanted to get something quiet and in
general Petrov is probably draw so oh
yeah
um and he surprised me with Knight C6
Bishop 5 and I couldn't remember my
preparation because it's a lot
most
challenging line for white yeah yeah
um I couldn't remember my preparation
and I just played some random stuff and
it didn't work out really well and his
play was A3 I remember was some kayaking
game in Canada's 2018 I think but
nothing more I could remember that's
kind of for uh perhaps the first big
game in this particular line and he
tried this A3 yeah but I couldn't
remember the details what is the point
of A3 but
yeah I just this game was nothing
special yeah he played very good the H6
move is brilliant
um normalist and risky to play H6 but he
knew the plans so
picking of opening preparation and being
so difficult to get anything with the
white pieces especially
um how do you generally prepare for this
type of tournaments classical events
specifically yeah it's not easy for
um you should be a bit lucky always to
pick up a win in this kind of tournament
for instance Wesley against me was lucky
and also many other guys here that mean
you have to you kind of win by opening
so
um
you have to use your chances and
processing especially a good Advantage
out of opening which is the most painful
thing because you cannot ever get
advantages against obviously but
um yeah it's difficult but you have to
work hard right and that's one of the
things right Wesley feels like a counter
puncher right he waits Waits Waits and
if you over push then he Strikes Back
how would you characterize your style
are you a counterparter are you taking
more risks in general can you just take
more risks and that's why you lose more
points than wasting but you also win yes
I like a lot yes for sure but
um basically it's always like at the top
in grandchild stores so for instance
last year also he was competing against
him so
his stone is more stable than me but he
gets less wins also than me so the make
it's a different type of
styles
alireza at the big topic of discussion
has been your fashion side career now I
see you're making some fashion
statements with these clips on I really
like them how is that going
um yeah it's I think in general I wanted
to always have something outside of
Chess because it's
just to play your whole life chess is
not it's a bit weird for me so
um but I always loved playing chess but
the fact that I'm living in Paris now
and everything is in that direction
um there is a good opportunity there but
in general I'm still in chess of course
are you enjoying that yeah yeah for sure
it's a new chapter and I like this how
the things going and why not combine
both of them right alireza thank you
very much for joining us uh I'll see you
around thank you guys back to you thank
you Christian you do make it clear to
Ali that he has two people who want to
wear his swag so he'll have at least two
customers in St Louis uh ready to
support whatever he comes up with all
right as we prepare for our break we
check in our good friends at Q Boutique
as what have we got today we have a
popular item it's a super soft women's
gray pocketed cardigan featuring The
Grand Chester logo on the bottom left
pocket
this and all the great St Louis chess
club items are available at Q Boutique
St louis.com be sure to order yours and
we'll see you on the other side of the
commercial break
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
over the roughly one and a half
Millennium of its existence chess has
been known as a tool of military
strategy a metaphor for human affairs
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back everyone
as we see this beautiful playing Hall is
uh round three underway with only one
result a draw in the game between Ali
Reza and Richard Rapport one of our
tournament co-leaders Richard making a
very comfortable draw with black Ollie
Raisa saying yeah well it's really hard
to get something against the Russian
defense he didn't conjure up anything
special and the other four games uh big
fights all around we do think that
Fabiano
is in a great position and most likely
going to win we thought that
um ding Loren played a horrible opening
but his father's way back into
contention and where a draw is the most
likely as again four games in progress
and we just seen this move F7 F5 I must
say that's a little bit a surprising
move to me in the game between Wesley so
and Anish Gary I think we were focusing
on F6 well so earlier I was
doing seven with
four immediate it right here yes uh this
was our primary move yes G4 he took took
took took and then went G4
yeah you would think that the it wasn't
like the bishop was running away anytime
soon takes takes and here we thought a a
draw was most likely after F7 F6 he
played F5
and
I don't know Uh something's not bad well
I want to play Rook H1 Rook H7 right I
mean if I could get my Rook uh involved
in
uh in in that okay
so Amazon if I can't play Rook H1 I
don't want you to to play F5 therefore I
feel the moment you play F4 sorry let me
let me make this clear I make a bad move
uh
what's a bad move there you go the
moment you play F4 I'm no longer
uh tethering The Rook is is free
essentially and once you go Rook h8 I
mean I might start liking Black's
position very very shortly so uh
amperson King takes F6 I'm assuming Rook
H1
black looks better but it's not going
going to be easy to keep improving
and to actually convert this into a win
do you know these Bishops of opposite
color ending just what Richard uh
enjoyed uh yesterday there is a problem
though the pawn is
a Target and I am
ready to play Rook H7 and he rooked G7
ideas you know okay let me just put a
movie a pleasant end game for Wesley
right zero risk zero risk I haven't
sacrificed anything and I don't know uh
better for white maybe not enough to win
VAR but hey look I'll take it
yeah absolutely it's uh clearly better
for Wesley here but I've been uh going a
little bit deeper analyzing some of the
moves and it's not so clear because it
doesn't look like you're going to be
able to win the G5 pawn cleanly and once
you play the move F4 you're gonna have a
pass Pawn on the G4 but it's going to be
very hard to advance here so we can take
a look at some of the lines to see how
white can try to make progress here so
he takes F6 King F6 plate yep so very
logical to start with the move Rook H1
here for sure then
um black can play C5 okay
and uh let's say Rook H6 check
okay Rook G6 we don't want to trade
Rooks because if we trade Rooks it's
just going to be a draw there is sure no
other way to attack on G5 so let's say
we play Rook H7 right so this might be a
little bit passive but you have to play
the move Bishop F7 okay and um
for now
it's hard to see how y can try to make
progress you can try to maybe play B3 or
you can play Bishop D2 I was looking
Rook G8 for example
Bishop C3 check
but now the king can return to G6 okay
and now we have to move the Rook back so
clear it's definitely better for white
but it's not easy to see how to make
progress perhaps you can try to maybe
Advance some of the pawns with B3 A4 and
try to create maybe a second weakness on
the queen side
all right again it's uh one of those
confounding positions where it does look
like white has a lot of uh things uh
going in his favor but maybe it's not
enough let's just check in because it's
so fresh in our melons this world
championship match uh between dingler in
and uh
nepo uh you know it was funny we were on
break and you were telling me this move
King D7 yes and that was a very
important move uh that uh ding needs to
include and I'm not exactly sure if it
was this position but yeah it wasn't
Rook takes I think it was Kim D7 right
here and that was the right move uh the
whole point is that uh well with this
move King D7 played on the board you
don't have to worry about rookie one
check Rook C8 it was sort of quickly I
want to include the other Rook into the
game play Rook V8 possibly so that when
white takes on C4 we have a Target on B2
exactly King D7 Rook takes D5
uh
uh just a second can we grab this Pawn
suddenly on C4
yeah Bishop takes C4 with the idea Rook
takes F5 I'm I'm I'm eyeballing a shish
kebab
uh Al Castle here Castle yes is that
legal you're sure I think so okay
yeah that looks fine
yeah but no Bishop's about so I'm gonna
have to
secure the night
uh I was about to say I think I'm gonna
have to include G4 but we do have a
breaking result Fabiano said hey guys uh
three players type first got a room up
there for me I'd like to be the fourth
as uh we had an opening that just went
wrong another way of putting it for MBL
after the move Knight B2 to D3 Fabby
said
yeah wow when you can get in that move
that is Central Pawn Duo first of all it
shuts down uh any self-respecting
Bangkok player will not appreciate
having the dark Square uh Bishop closed
off
F5 oh
that looks gross Knight H2 Queen H3
Knight E2 and mvl said I just don't have
a move if I capture on F4 pardon me if I
capture on E5 Knight F4 is going to trap
my queen
if I don't capture I've got I'm facing
yeah broke D3 and exactly nothing like
it's out of most here so that's why he
resigned you you might think it's
premature because it's early but Black's
position was pretty hopeless here it
feels like a complete opening debacle
here I don't recall
seeing mvl losing inside of two dozen
moves yeah anybody any of these players
actually but so we have a big big win
for Fabi
[Music]
and three games still going on exactly
okay let's jump back to that dingler in
uh versus
uh
oh they did play our wait really what
really what what just a second hold on
uh I was about to say that I I wanted to
take Bishop C4 back because yeah you
played the move castles and I didn't I
didn't think that that was possible I
was about to I was just about to suggest
G4 uh when we caught up with the players
Bishop C4 Bishop B3 castles
I'm guessing he wants to play Bishop
takes A4
um did he do this right uh VAR
no I think nepo completely misplayed it
now and now ding is back in a game again
yeah again yeah it's a hot potato
between these two guys huh yeah they're
going back and forth here there are a
couple of things I want to show you guys
here let's take a look let's go back a
few moves here uh when we are on a break
uh we were we were discussing the that
in this position blocks only move here
is actually to play King D7 this is the
only move to try to keep the position
balanced here the the idea here is if
you play KD7 if you take immediately on
C4 black has this tricky move and it's
the only move here Bishop to D2
attacking The Rook here and you don't
have a good Square on a C file to go to
uh but if you move away you're losing
the bishop here and now if you play
Bishop takes B3 Bishop takes C1 and uh
you can play let's say Bishop takes A4
Rook takes a four Rook C1 you can get
this position but after Rook B8 black
should be able to hold this position I
don't think he has winning chances but
you know he can definitely hold this so
this is what ding had to do to play the
move King this time but he didn't he
played Rook takes D5 and it's very
strange decision here by nepo again he
moved very quickly here and we've seen
so many times she make an inaccuracy by
doing this he made quick quick move
again missed something he should have
just simply played the move G4 here
first securing the Knight on F5 and he
would have had a big Advantage here I
will show you the some of the lines now
so here G4 is an excellent move here
it's a natural move because you want to
secure the Knight on F5 and also the
Knight is doing a good job protecting
your Pawn on D4 so perhaps he maybe
didn't like this move Bishop D2 but now
against this move you can simply Play
Bishop takes C4 if Bishop takes on C4
Rook C4 you're very happy you're
threatening group C8 as well and if you
take on C1 now you have this idea Bishop
takes D5 first and the bishop takes D5
you capture
C8 ideas so probably King D7 Rook C5 and
this would have been a technically
winning end game for white I think
you're happy yeah but instead he played
a quick move here did not play the move
G4 he played Bishops takes a C4
immediately and now Rook takes F5 only
move
because if you take on C4 first Rook
takes C4 Rook F5 there is a rook CA
check here and secure a skewer and
winning The Rook on h8 so that's why we
saw the move Rook text F5 played
immediately by Ding and now Bishop takes
B3 and
perhaps he just simply missed that black
and still Castle because we are on move
number 26 to 27 here and being just
quickly castle and I saw
um Nepal shaking his head here and he is
not happy he missed something here and
uh he probably has to take now on A4
he's done that he's done that okay so
Bishop takes 84 oh you don't think so I
apologize and now ah maybe he missed
this this is interesting Rook to F4
check
King E3
and um
deflecting the king from E3 now and now
you have to take otherwise your Rook is
hanging and Rook will take on D4
King C3
and we're gonna go to Christian in
Romania
thanks for we are here with a big Victor
of today's round there is Fabiano
caruana who took down mvl Fabi first of
all a big surprise in the opening you
started off with D4 we've seen those
Tendencies from you but then at move
three you play this move H4 tell us a
bit about that
yeah well I
am a few years behind the times I think
his age four got really popular again
it's like an kind of invention of
grishuk like so many opinion ideas these
days and it got really really popular
and Maximus faced it many times and I
actually wasn't surprised that he
decided to go for the benko against it
because
um I don't know if you remember his his
game with the white pieces against Peter
squidler
it reached this position and Maxine
himself against Peter played uh
played this
and they kind of reached
they they reached
a game which Maxine kind of won very
very brilliantly
uh 98 or okay one king f8
and uh I think like simply like H5 here
and he won a brilliant game but at some
point the engine in that game I think
was giving black decent chances yeah it
was it was a four-star if black was
playing it correctly and so I wasn't too
surprised I kind of knew that you can
also play like this it's basically a
Banco Gambit where white for absolutely
no reason for the pawn in H4 so it's
like it's the best benko you could have
but uh but it is
this move I didn't know okay it looked
very natural to do this but yeah I only
played rookie one when I saw this bishop
G5
because if I play E5 then tag Rook takes
Rook fd8 I thought it's very unclear yes
but Bishop G5 is strong I thought he
would go for this position here
I thought if he takes with the bishop
unfortunately I have this very strong
rookie for queen of five and queen E2
and I think he just gets crushed
basically because I collected yeah
whatever I want so he he should probably
play ef6 yeah and I thought like I can
play Rook C1 here he's not and if I get
b39 B5 then I have a good position
um I know sorry no Knight B5 first yeah
because I forced Rook fd8 probably and
now I was thinking okay Rook C1 but I
wasn't sure about F5 here Rook C4 fe4
Rook here Queen F5 I thought it's super
dangerous for black but
still this is something a long way to
win to win the game very good
calculation so
so then he surprised me I didn't think
this move was possible
but it took me a long time to calculate
this G3 and Knight bd3 because it still
looks pretty scary right kind of like I
think wins for black if not for Knight
G5 yeah or at least very dangerous but I
saw this move and I was trying to figure
out these complications I was a bit
confused but I think Maxim said after
the game the bishop takes a fate and
then Knight B5 is a very important move
and uh like the D3 Maybe
just from three three yeah it's it's
complex but it kind of doesn't work but
I thought he should probably go for it
because it's a difficult Choice here
which work to take with
um this at first I didn't even
understand his point and then I
understood that that this is actually
getting a little bit unclear
it looks like dead lost I mean
by all means it is except that he has
this Knight C3 and I wasn't sure I
thought like
I thought this might be kind of Winnie
but then I saw this 92 move and I got a
bit scared but I see the computers as
king H2 so but okay I was I was thinking
that this this could be winning 94 and
some move like it looked like something
here should be 1935. it seems yeah but
then I thought okay why why not have
this is Queen B3 I mean
um
there was one moment even after this
move F5 which I think from a practical
perspective was definitely
um the right choice if it goes to D4
what was your plan at this point okay so
first I was going to repeat once yeah
and then I was going to think about the
earlier position so the point is like
Rook D1 looks very very strong but this
this end game
I wasn't sure I thought it's probably
winning like okay I can go for this it's
kind of safe yeah but all my pawns are
weak so you can see drawing chances here
if things go wrong so I was going to
either go for this
um or okay at first I'll repeat and here
I saw a move which looked really
tempting which was the move um
Queen D1 I think
and for Rook D3 so I thought Knight D3
Queen D3
um FG then I probably even have like 94
stuff
um yeah so so I thought he takes FG
first and I was going to like calculate
this position but I didn't see how he
probably doesn't have enough composition
yeah I mean it's a piece and he's not
talking about so many pieces so uh but I
thought I might as well include throw
this in because okay Queen Street is
clearly just like you no longer have
threats right I think he was counting on
this suddenly oh um no no not this Rook
D1 no um
this is terrible for uh but Bishop C5
looks super super
um winning but then I saw that he has
some move here like Bishop takes E5 I'm
sorry uh Rook takes E5 and D6 King h8
rookie five Bishop B5 I mean it must be
completely winning but I started to get
a bit confused because Bishop before
this bishop G3 and okay obviously so I
started to get a little bit worried here
but
I mean it's not even spotted it just
really really kills him very nice uh
game with the white piece is quite an
encouraging sign for your tournament
starting off uh with Blast how do you
feel about the event so far how do you
feel about your shape up to this point
yeah I missed something big in the first
game but today I feel like I calculated
well and
to be fair I think Maxine wasn't was
playing far from his best today I mean
he he really didn't um
like he missed Bishop takes E7 he said
so this is a sign that he was really not
in good form today but I did what I had
to do so overall it's good Bobby
definitely took advantage of your
opportunities in this one
congratulations we'll see you in the
next few games thanks
thank you Christian if you could ask
Fabi did he when was the last time he
won and just two dozen moves uh winning
out of the opening is rare especially in
the 2800 clubs
so what the Yasser is asking is when is
the last time that you can remember when
you won more or less out of the opening
and a class will get let me know because
Robin Blitz probably happens quite often
um in a classical game let me think I
think against uh gukash and Vikings it
wasn't like out of the opening but I got
a really really huge Advantage more or
less by move 15 and I more or less
always kept the advantage it wasn't like
this where it was like let's say plus
four but it was kind of plus two and and
stayed around there yeah
um but it's so difficult yeah that was
still like a long amuent more or less to
the end game so it was something like
this it has been quite a long time
there you have it yeah a rare indeed to
win our congratulations Bobby as he
pulls himself uh into this group of
leaders and uh let's uh tune into one of
them uh Wesley so versus Anish uh one of
these Bishops of opposite color Berlin
uh positions uh Wesley's for choice but
it looks like black can hold us it
really does it just has that complete
feel especially now that the bishop has
aimed itself properly I want to put it
that way against the pawn on F3 this
looks like it's heading uh towards a
draw uh when we left it we really I
really like duda's position but the more
I've been looking at it recently uh the
less enamored I am with it Rook D2 maybe
this whole uh very well timed
E7 E6 this bishop on B7 which is dormant
is suddenly about to burst free and uh
maybe the worst is behind it definitely
looks that way like this uh black is
back in the game
the counter play looks very good it does
indeed very much so and dingler and
that move
oh pardon me he did not play Bishop
takes A4 but that that moved Bishop D2
really left a very nice visual
impression Savar had pointed out that
the desirable Bishop takes A4 is met by
Rook takes Chad King E3 you may be
having dreams of Nursing and upon up
ending after moves like Rook C4 but
Bishop D2
that just is very nice as that makes uh
Black's life much much more simple which
is why in this exact position we saw the
move instead of Rook C4 we're caught up
to the players
um
first impressions as Bishops of opposite
color positions again I think ding's
chances of making a draw suddenly do you
think uh ding should exchanged the
Bishops and go into the Rook end game
I'm not so sure I like the bishop coming
to D2 but uh let me interrupt myself and
throw it back to Christian in Bucharest
with a very special guest
we do have indeed a very special I guess
Gary first of all welcome back to the
show we haven't seen you since uh day
one how did you experience the first uh
couple of rounds here at the super
Adventures class uh there are many draws
but uh I have to say that it's it's not
because of the lack of the fighting
spirit so and
clearly you know you we could see
yesterday
they will try uh to win the game just
you know until the very last pawn and I
think it was a bit shocking to see how
do they managed to lose this this end
game but you know it's quite amazing I
think it's this it's it's it's it's it's
again the game is not you know just it
doesn't make a front page newspaper but
it's an interesting moment because I
mean it was it was dead draw of course
absolutely that draw uh no that's I can
tell you what's happened it's a sea
plate B5 you know this it's uh uh
thinking that you can force draw though
he didn't have whatever K5 I mean H5 I
mean any movement probably would be a
draw in a few a few moves but but the
five one take I think he missed Bishop
takes me one before and before which is
very very nice but before fix the pawn
on B5 now it's probably still you know
okay okay black is already struggling
because it's they're losing the pawn but
the the typically one even sometimes two
Pawns in in opposite color Bishops and
games it's not a big deal but this was
very unusual structure because black had
too many weaknesses yeah as many
typically
it's F7
G6 potentially if you start moving pawns
there so normally you know they say oh
you have to put your your your pawns on
the on on the opposite colors of your
Bishop
but uh that's actually worked very much
in in in
rapport's favor yeah because in the
white phones you know um trap black
bishop and uh it's limited these
movements why black bones you know were
excellent targets
I won't be surprised I don't know I have
not know this game but the G5 wasn't
decisive mistake it was I think it's
just instinctively because you know it's
you have many weaknesses and you have to
start thinking which again is still it's
tough because you know losing B5 form
and then C Pawn will be moving and then
all these pawns will be weak I think
it's probably I would probably play H5
H4 just you know exchanging the pawns
but limiting number of the pawns yeah G5
I could and again brilliant F4 he fixed
the nut which is interesting B4 fix one
with this and then
I don't know why you play G5 because
it's so natural because after B4 you
know he could have expected F4 and now
the moment I saw it I just we discussed
it here and said look with too many
weaknesses
think you know it's it's it's it's lost
again I haven't followed the game in
details but very very instructive end
game very instructive there's so many
storylines and specifically today of
course everybody's eyes were on that
game nepo versus yes yes things what did
you expect before the game no I expected
it would be a big fight and and of
course you know never playing white so
it would give him a chance to take some
sort of the psychological or just moral
revenge for for Austin and uh and he has
been trying he has been trying so he
played D4 it's the it seems that he is
he has only four so um but it just shows
that you know he had plenty of ideas
there for the match well prepared and
and I think it's a very interesting game
you know this is again the many chess
fans they sing Oh Queen's gone not a big
deal but we're now from Berlin that is
just you know disappearance of Queens
doesn't mean that the game is dull it
could be very interesting very
entertaining of course we had one Berlin
today
yeah but
um also this it's a very interesting
position I remember first time I
analyzed it in depths before match was
Nigel because Nigel played this this uh
this uh classical uh
Queen's Gambit with Bishop yes but yes
yeah he hasn't played the match but we
analyzed it before the match was Queen
and through this end game though I have
to say that you know I I was I was
planning to play H4 in another night of
H4 which is again it's not the move it's
this uh it seems that the the lately the
move has been not refused uh not not
refuted but uh black neutralized and I'm
not afraid it's I think it's kramnik's
idea yes it's just this oh yes Carlson I
think Carlson
exactly yes it's Carlson so it's this
with Knight on H4 and then pushing FM
and it was very interesting in it it's
whether it was prepared by Dean or not
but I I was quite you know intrigued by
the position after Bishop C2 because
that was a plan so this is and uh F4 now
he wants he wants to push the the pawn
and and
um and black okay black black has to
bring Knight on night night on night on
D6 but it's just it's it's a long way so
and Bishop C2 and that was interesting
one do you think he missed this move
right to B1 because according to the
engine at least at this point white was
borderline winning look it seemed it
seems to me that white has a huge
Advantage now because of this is the you
know F5 is is is is is a problem the
square of five and uh and uh just you
know removing bishop and basically
keeping this Knight you know total
controller five square I mean paralyzes
the black position because this bishop
has it's very hard to move because night
night will be cutting the bishop so um
the whole idea of you know playing f54
what did he prepared it I don't know
just it's I didn't follow the A5 was the
first time where he spent quite a lot of
time to it yeah that's that's that's
probably you know probably D4 was a
surprise to him uh uh he came up with
this you know with this plan D5 and
seems to me that was his plan for the
match to play solid games and in that
point now after he played Knight B1 he
said ah I could have played it in the
last rapid game I bet you that came
through his mind I could have played in
the last rapid game and that this is the
position I could have yeah in the last
moment so
um
um and after that'd be one I thought
it's really difficult for black and and
I immediately saw the C5 he had to play
C5 at one point so and and again I don't
know what this is Rook A5 which is the
interesting idea because the uh I think
the idea was that after 95 no no here
for 95 Knight B6 Knight D2 and now
Bishop C4 I think that's that's that's I
guess that was that was yeah because
night night is hanging and yeah and then
it's just you know and then you go B5
and it's maybe still maybe an unpleasant
but the kid pawns are stronger yes
exactly yes so yes yes before yes there
would be five Industries is taking D7
and they just you bring it up back and
yeah it's maybe it's I don't know still
still looks just looks doesn't look good
to me so listen it looks like a center
but you have something to play for maybe
yes that's the I just again I I don't
think that's that's it's the bishop E2
and he played with C5 here he played the
season Yes actually I think maybe here
white couldn't even played King of two
you know just I don't understand because
I'm not sure let's see before just it
makes much sense it's just okay
but in general so and explain Knight B6
I don't know what's the what about
what's what's Black's next move now
maybe even if I play something with
Knight C3 I don't know I'm not sure
because
C4 Square
you don't really want the place no but
that's but that's that's exactly what
because people are not be not D2 and
then and then and then so this is yeah
and and Nepal wanted to to force it
again I just don't know that's those my
thoughts and and then ding you know I
think he found the only move 98 and B5
again it still may not be enough to save
the game but that was the only chance
otherwise black would lose just you know
the total paralysis yeah this white will
start improving the position at the 5G 4
H and then eventually E4 will win the
game so
um he uh here so in the game it was yes
nice D1 91 right C3 back 97 but now
finally you have big exactly that's all
because the key is after Bishop are free
so B5 if he is simply B5 and you can
take on D5 yes yeah the take that before
and Knight is hanging yeah that's nice
yes yes that's nice yes that's that's an
idea that's the one otherwise you know
he could have parallel this Knight and
Bishop on the faith you cannot you
cannot win the win they win The Rook
there so that's that's their Bishop yeah
you still wants
yeah and if you take there this bishop
before was checked so so uh I think
that's the that was the only chance and
being founded and and then uh I think
NEPA also recognized that he should yeah
should stop I don't know this is after
E4 you understand there was nowhere he
had to play before now yes seems like B4
was the best yeah because this otherwise
again of just white will have decided
look at this Bishops yeah so before
take take Knight takes Knight takes and
here is here's a surprise like fairly
quickly
yeah why not G4 that's a very good
question yeah this is Steve why don't
you four you're right C4 yeah but you
have a knight on F5 I mean this is
totally paralyzed position and I don't
know what what I can do
there's something about his conversion
nepo's conversion in the match under
five you know this is it just it's it's
totally held this position blacks that
holds the black position under you know
uh almost paralysis yeah and I next take
Next Movement yeah I'm I don't know
Bishop D2 still bishopsy four years
yeah
I think so you get this position Bishop
takes D5 root takes C1 I mean this is
such a yeah
foreign
why not G4 yeah yeah very odd very odd
so this is the and this is something
that Richard report also mentioned when
he came here
um following the match and being so
close to ding he noticed that Neville
has huge problems converting converting
his advantages and this is exactly what
we're seeing uh so what's what's
happened on this is he going to the same
game yesterday yeah um so after Castle
take take Rook do you want Rook to d8
King to D3 and F5 Rook to B4 trying to
at some point take an H5 this is the
position
horror his chance is looking to convert
this one
so you should believe something like
Rook E2 King c yeah but what H4 H3
that's that's already he's pushing yes
H3 now is right now yes or maybe he
wants to start with Rook G4 and then
yeah because by this but the king C3
Rook D2 and take the pawn yeah that's
that's the that's the that's the plan
yeah and maybe black should play Rogue
but once you get to that point do I have
some ideas so for example let's say I go
here you go here already Rook to E4
first I was booking C3
God
yeah and now maybe Rook to E4
you try to find some counter play like
this
yeah
so I'm still a fight no no no no rook's
end game always a fight yeah that's all
the fight so that's it yeah especially
against very few points left
um and black to create some counter play
so yeah yeah I mean
um
I would say that like never had such a
good position
yeah we're in the middle of uh round
three who's making which player is
making an impression on
you look this is it's a very very even
field very even field and uh I think
it's rarely we have tournaments where
near every player you know could
could so many decides of games but it's
not because of the lack of fighting
Spirit but more because they they
they're all good so that's the by I
think that's that's the main reason and
uh and I you know I think it's it's very
very entertaining tournament so I I
don't know what's happening with mvl
today I mean it collapsed yeah very
quickly so it seems that you know that
H4 move three you know
it's just you know again it's to me it's
quite an odd you know move because I
played kicks Indian and that's that's
Kings you're welcome yeah I don't know
look they believe that King Sydney is a
bad opening so that's why you can even
play with H4 so
um but um and you can walk again with
optic from my Optics you know he had a
very good position I don't know this
this day but
I looked elsewhere and it came back just
look at the screen because it's gone
game was over yes game is over here so
um uh but again all games are
interesting so that's this is Simone
again traditional Berlin it's still you
know it's amazing the playground
every tournament you know just the
little bits you know right and left you
know just improvements but it's still
interesting fight yeah okay this this
game probably is it's it's a Droid yeah
not a big deal we've had some chances
but but yet he but he had some
what's the real good chance for white I
mean um
yeah Rook D1 yes Bishop yes uh what
about 95 here yes
tactically it works because Bishop G5
you have F6 ideas
um but of course Rook to G8 is not the
only move you can go king of fa uh
taking fac4 yeah
you don't want to touch that yeah the
young boy G6 because of Bishop D5 yes
that's true that's true yes
the idea just pushing this yeah it
looked a bit dangerous to me though
that's again that's the way I they can
I'm not pretending to be a big expert in
Berlin but this is you have other
players you know who know it much but
but still again Optics yeah yeah I
thought maybe it's a bit difficult but
it's this but
yeah that's the idea just to
you know and what about E6 I mean I know
it's primitive about this what about E6
years before yeah here it is E60 yeah
yeah and after X is six
75 and for whatever reason the engine is
saying that the two Bishops are just
strong very very strong
you cannot get C4 going because B3 all
the time
engine ideas
I'm still struggling to to
so I still play C3 so I'm just you know
I'm
it should be seven years
yeah it's just a G7 Pawn is Untouchables
yeah I'm still you know why
why I want an impression that you feel
like white has a grip on the position
you know just again maybe it's
to leave up there free now
yeah
see okay so Rook H5 you actually want to
take that pawn mostly I'm not sure let's
let's try it out
D1 let's say I I cannot go there because
see take take
so let's defend this guy
Bishop six next yeah
so I have to say um
B3 and c4u C5 that's the problem so
yeah that's um
bring some
sad memories to me of your 2000 but
let's give credit to Chrome links so we
came up with the one of the most
stunning discoveries of 21st century
that was already done
bringing bringing the still probably the
most popular yes yes that's again just
recognizing the the potential of this
opening Gary thank you very much always
great I think there is
[Music]
versus who you mentioned is struggling
this one against bogdon Daniel Dak and
they're actually getting in time travel
right now they're only 33 seconds this
is one of his biggest issues he always
gets in time
it's it's very unpleasant I don't think
is okay do the let's assume do they will
play this end game better than he would
yesterday yeah so what's the how many
moves left
there's still 11 12 moves 23 seconds 25
and Counting yes okay against five
minutes and 30 seconds
but what
thank you
I guess
I mean he has taken right the Knight on
B6 is not doing anything
played with seven seconds Knight takes
C8
they were expecting latex before which
he does
still equal parts but no it's a solo
pawns it's about it's white totally
dominates if a free can give two Knight
D4 Rook C2 this this I think I would say
people play A5 probably now
so you would give big chances to do that
to convergence you'd play five fingers
at least try to do something yes
maybe I don't know but just at least
maybe Knight goes on D6 and yeah and
then okay
no no no no 94.
what you did is 94. yeah that's okay
no Knight E4 black can play 94.
oh um no no this is this so it's white
to move right now
Knight 26 I was just playing yeah yeah
so now this one didn't take them on B7 I
take yes they could not be so nice
history yeah
but um
same game but it's very important yeah
very very unpleasant so what's this even
if it makes almost almost indefensible
yes
again it's uh yeah if you make time
control still you know that's uh even
without rules you know the end game
might be very unpleasant but can limit
the number of Pawns yeah let's see here
let's see if Dura you know manager
saying it gets a bit nervous now
so it's a tough thing is yesterday yeah
Miracles handling yeah
right like how do you recovery
but that's you know that's what happens
with people often they don't understand
is that it's you know it's he was he
totally relaxed I mean the game was over
I mean he just stopped thinking yeah
and then
you have to start it's very difficult
because he already switched off I think
his his senses yeah and then after
before he realized that ah I I have to
think and it's immediately you know this
is his first challenge you know he just
made immediately
Panic at that point it's it's not so
much Panic it's just you know it's very
difficult to come back because you know
this is you started the game and you're
preparing you know you're just you're
mentally you're ready and then again
playing games over so give me probably
thinking about next tomorrow
yeah and all of a sudden
he takes the uh report to con D1 was a
bishop played before
just realized that something is wrong
and interesting immediately he makes a
decision
immediately that's that's the it's just
the first test
yeah
Gary okay as usual always great insights
thank you very much we'll see you around
yes thank you thank you Christian thank
you Gary uh The Passion of Gary Kasparov
a earlier question from uh the social
media was yes sir you get the
competitive juices well you can see Gary
you know he sits down and he says well
what's going on
and he doesn't want to get out he really
really enjoys analyzing uh let's pick up
uh win that game between Duda and diat
because time travel is a factor or is it
yeah I think a lot has happened since
last we looked at this position after
we're on move 22 one of the acquired E6
and it looked like black was equalizing
again okay but DIA has been in time
trouble for the past 10 moves and uh not
as increment of 30 seconds now he's in a
quote unpleasant end game
maybe it's not that bad but again he's
playing with just one minute on the
clock exactly so he's still relying and
which number uh which proves they still
have eight moves to go still eight moves
to go and this move Knight C5 really
just puts the question uh to uh
obviously takes and takes that's pretty
clear that's on uh White's agenda so
should we try to maintain the bishop for
just a moment let's uh let's move out of
the way right I think the egg would love
to exchange both of the minor pieces
game he actually reached for the night
and sorry please right in the Rook end
game he can defend down upon but if we
have Rooks and the Knight down upon
yeah that's not happiness yes so we just
we just saw the move Knight B6 and I
think Gary in his analysis with
Christian there was saying ooh ooh very
very very bad position you just play F3
you play King F2 uh Black's pieces are
bad especially get rid of his weakness
on A5 by plane A4
let's have a look so suppose I play F3
let's say you you would like to try A4
okay you know it's kind of strange I
think the Knight on B6 is bad but I'm
trying to get a good night versus bad
Bishop on B7 so if I were to for example
take take I see only two results I see
these past pawns over here you may
collect one of them but I'm thinking you
know like I can play moves like Knight
C3 Rook D4 King F2 and the idea was I
wanted you to play with the bad Bishop
yeah and torture black for 100 moves oh
yeah I was thinking 140 actually
and we do have F3 on the board we'll see
uh Knight B6 on the board F2 F3 just
asked and this is the question that you
had asked uh maybe it's time because if
you do nothing as Gary says
Knight C3 eventually
out yeah well here we go we're gonna get
that good night versus bad uh Bishop
position if he chooses Knight takes A4
all right and seven moves to go with uh
Jan having three minute and a half on
the clock and diak with 45 seconds
verusian we're seeing a very very
nervous dioc right now he's getting up
almost every move he he lost yesterday
this could be you know it gets bad when
they target you in these kinds of
tournaments yes he was also in time
travel in the first round against Fabi
and he survived that position so right
every game we see him so far he has a
time he should received in this position
guys I know you guys were looking at
taking on A4 here but actually white
maybe can just play the move Knight D4
here immediately
no F3 oh sorry now with it yeah okay and
the point here is you just the Knight is
really really bad on B6 and you want to
take back with the pawn yeah and there
are no good scores to go to and you have
to watch out for the a little bit of a
trick there Rook C7 if you go to Knight
E6 check
and sacrificing the Knight and then you
will Fork The Rook here so it's it's
it's a very nice Advantage for white and
uh I would say more unpleasant for black
to play because he has to find some
accurate moves and a contra play here
that's why I would like to put the
Knight on D4 here just to keep that
Knight on a really bad Square on B6 and
just to pick your brain for just a
moment if Knight takes A4 Knight takes
A4 B takes A4 I am getting this position
more or less of a bad Bishop on B7
versus a good knight uh Advantage white
but is it significant enough actually
that line is going to be just equal here
because I'm taking on A4 yeah Pawn takes
if there is a very strong move Rook E3
Ah that's true I don't have my king on
F2 yet right and yeah if you play King
F2 for example Rook was on A3 right it
will pick up the pawn on A4 so this will
actually rookie block is equalizing
so yeah that's why after the move A4
it's the best is just to play you can
start with the move King F2 or to play
the move Knight D4 both moves will offer
you really good chances here very good
thank you uh and do that for that down
to one minute and 22 seconds
so and he'd play King F2
uh
Nepal and ding we have a very equal end
game now
Racing for a draw
huh people I can take on G2
yep
and Nepal is has less time I think this
might be the first time it was been down
on the clock yes
I'm sorry to say that it was during the
Christian and Gary interview there I
really thought this Rook ending right
here after the move Rook E1 was very
much
in Jan's favor and I really didn't like
what he did after the move Rook d8
in my opinion if I were in white shoes I
really like this idea of King C3 and
just going after this Pawn I don't want
to allow Rook F2 so I would like to play
rookie 2 inviting you to capture and
this is where I think if I can play
three versus three but I'm the one with
B Pawn I think I'm happy to play on but
he instead he played this move King D3
and then after F5 H5 H4 it seemed to me
like ding.sufficient counter play on the
king side so that the world champion
could hold the game and it now seems as
you say that that a draw is
yeah a fair result how about Wesley
Wesley Anish when we left it
it seemed pretty even is it still the
case
still looks very even to me this is the
Bishops of opposite color
and
uh and they just made move for 40 so
they're gonna get additional 30 minutes
okay but I think
position is uh it's very easy to draw
for black maybe just play Rook F7 next
move and
that's it
can't uh can't argue the point uh
Bishop's opposite color so if I go
Bishop C3 Rook F7 I mean my king can
maybe Mosey in and and do some snacking
but is it it's probably not enough it
shouldn't work no well you you well
you'll keep you know like for example
even if I was to uh win a pawn you could
get a position where you could anchor
your bishop and just say okay you can't
win on The Queen side or the king side
so that game looks like a draw dingler
in uh game looks like a draw and it all
depends upon the outcome of deox
position uh in any case should we should
do to win he would only climb back to 50
he wouldn't join the leader Group which
currently comprises four players by the
way and plus one
still time control yes they still have
to make they still have formals to make
and I've I've noticed how diac always
just gets up from every word when he has
like a minute on the clock right yeah
Rook a
rook C7 I reminded of what you said
vivar if the Knight had been on D4 that
Rook on C7 that would have been a a
taboo Square uh
it still is it's nice for white right
it's very unpleasant still Rook A5
you've got kind of a dark Square
blockade the Knight is going to come to
D4 this King E3 maybe King E3 King D4 on
a good day and no counter play
absolutely still very unpleasant and uh
dayak needs to survive the next three
moves first right and make sure he
doesn't worsen the position more here
but it's very easy to play for white you
know I think a knight will go to D4 next
and King E3 I wouldn't mind actually
even putting the pawn on G4 here yes or
just to restrict that uh bishop and gain
some more space there and this Knight on
B6 is really misplaced and that's the
reason I think it's good to keep the
pawn on B3 for now just improve the
position to the maximum and then later
on try to perhaps Advance the spawn
that's why I like this move Rook A5 it's
just uh taken away that C4 Square from
the Knight yeah exactly I really do I I
wholeheartedly agree Rook A5 maintaining
the Knight on the very strong C5 Square
prepping
future G4 Knight D4 King E3 uh again
it's
very uncomfortable for black as he's
just I like this uh this comment of uh
Michael Marin where he said
one player is doing the other is
watching you know and it's sort of like
white is doing this Knight to D4 King D3
and black and is just watching and
waiting and waiting uh also by the way I
like this move Knight D3 as well
Exchange in our good night exactly uh
just okay gift me the pawn and again uh
oh
okay
I didn't anticipate that move can I just
grab the pawn I I thought Knight F6 was
going to defend and then I was going to
go Knight to D4 but Rook C2 so he's
offering up the pawn
Rook takes I have seven seconds on the
clock seven it's like oh boy okay so I
assume
this is his intention right something
like this he's sacrificing a pawn but at
least he's got in this case an active
Rook and even Bishop maybe yeah so you
can play Rook C5 instead of Rook d8 just
try to trade of course and
well Duda said show me
seven seconds he played Rook C2 Rook
takes E5 and uh what VAR was just
mentioning is
after Knight F6 there is this move Rook
C5 any trade of the Rooks would be
welcome because then the passer
would have one less blockader to deal
with Rook C5 ooh
um help me out here what is the
follow-up to uh the pawn sacrifice
that's it's a clear look A2 yeah it's a
clear upon Advantage here and uh I think
they're just trying to activate these
pieces hoping maybe to get that Bishop
on A6 here
um let's see Rook A2 and now just King
E3 right just getting out of the pit yes
and um Knight F6
Rook C5
Bishop E6
Bishop B6
night if you go the and my intention was
to take the pawn on G2 if you go to
Knight D4
10 seconds
well now Duda has four seconds on the
clock oh my gosh okay
he made a move on with how many seconds
now it is he's got like 30 how much how
much move forward 34. so yeah okay but
he played the move with four seconds on
this clock okay I always wondered I've
never seen it happen but I've always
wondered if you had like three seconds
four seconds in this case and you just
decided to make the most god-awful
sneeze of all time right like ah shoe
and totally distracted I'm sorry
but they both reached time control now
they're they made their 40th moves so
okay no more time trouble so we do have
the situation King E3 Knight F6 on the
board
right here
and it's an extra Pawn how serious is
this advantage of our
okay it's a it's an extra Pawn Plus uh
1.5 here actually for white 1.5 yeah
it's still technical yeah still
technical there's still The Rook is
actually quite active here on A2 so you
need to try to figure out the way to
trade it or maybe try to move that Rook
from there if you can get like maybe G4
and Knight D4 and play like Rook C2 or
something like that but we can take a
look at some of the the lines now since
they made the time control here so uh
the act just played Knight Knight F6
here and white has few options rookie 5
is a move but I I like Rook C5 bear it's
a more logical move here putting
pressure on the bishop on C8 here and
black can play here Bishop A6
is one option here G4 or oh sorry G4
even just played before here now you're
threatening to play B5 to shut down the
bishop okay and now Bishop will take on
D3
King takes D3
Rook B2 and here actually you have to
move Rook B5
because if you play the pawn to B5 then
if you had one more move here try to put
the Knight on City then you'll be just
just winning here but here there is this
line where your Rook gets under attack
here look
here some Knight B6 ideas
so let's check out the Wesley game guys
yeah and we have an opposite color and I
think this game will end in a draw
shortly black can just simply play C4
put the pawn on B5 and it will be a
fortress here
so I believe in that Fortress yes
and just A4 and just
so today both Burlington
yeah it's the bane of uh E4 players I
must say that uh
you just you just can't get an edge and
by the way I think it's a nice move A5
as he's saying okay if I could play put
my Pawn on A4 my Bishop on B3 I've got
the most uh perfect blockade ever here
A4
was that clever of Wesley to play B4 I
think Wesley was just trying to make an
offer of a draw
and he's instead kind of gifted the only
way for Wesley to lose here is to give
up his bishop and his pawns and not
bring the king
to anyone you're making a compelling
argument that this game should be drawn
okay yes I I I would assume that they
they will agree uh to a draw very
shortly
and the network thing we still have a
very equal Rook end game
because we are awaiting a handshake as
the players uh figure out a three move
repetition Bishop C1
two
they're waiting and thinking who's going
to call the arbit are you or me right
handshake
draw as uh Wesley with his plus one
score coming in today's competition he
was tied for first he remains yes tied
for first
as we have nepo dingler in
this is this Rook ending where more or
less we've been expecting a draw what
has happened somehow I didn't expect to
exchange a lot of Pawns
they did they did and yeah more exchange
is coming
would you take on B2 or D4 first after
let's say King takes F5
um
both
I'd like to take I guess the pawn on B2
uh Japan on D4 I would consider least
dangerous kind of thing you know because
I've got this beautiful blockading King
whereas if I had allowed my opponent to
play the move b2b3 I would be thinking
to myself why didn't I just take a take
that guy off the board right away so
yeah I would think Rook takes B2 but I
suspect we're already in such garage
territory VAR that either either one
should be enough for a draw absolutely
yes or yeah just many many moves will
lead to a draw here it's just if you
look at the material all white pawns are
split and it's hard to get any any
winning chances here we can look at some
of the lines for example if you play B4
here
try to advance the B Pawn just King
takes D4
Rook F3 now trying to take the pawn on
F5 King C4 King takes F5
and now you can just play King takes
before Rook F4 check and now King will
quickly run back to the f8 tier
King D6 and with the H Pawn we know
you're not gonna get much chances to win
here just and the pawn is not even
advanced yet so I think there should be
a draw very shortly and it's a great
escape for dingleren yeah considering he
was just losing out of the opening by
the way I think that this is a model
game for both players because in the
post-mortem nepo can come and say I'm a
complete idiot I was winning and I was
winning and I did I didn't and Dean can
come and say you know like yes I was
very lucky I I misplayed opening badly
and I should lose but I was very lucky
so both players will be uh it will suit
their personalities yes their post uh
gave my personality uh King D5 and then
finally Duda uh we do have this position
after the move Knight F6 I think dude is
still on move we'd like this Rook C5 a
lot because it gains a Tempo gif me the
bishop and after Bishop A6 the move B4
B5 funnily enough I didn't find myself
attracted to that I don't know exactly
why rather I I desperately want to play
the move Knight D4 but I don't want to
lose my G Pawn yes so I was much more
attracted not to B4 but to G4 which is
kind of funny because then once I get my
oops excuse me because then once I get
my knight to the D4 Square well that's
Harmony
I think dude has taken your advice from
yesterday I believe that on 41 yes you
take your time right you don't make a
quick move like he did yesterday right
exactly so he will take his time to
decide if he should give up the G2 Pawn
or
keep it alive and play G4
well with time control reach I think
it's a good moment for us this is ease
in one more break but
um on our break uh well Christian was in
uh Bucharest he got a chance to ask the
fans Not The Players but the fans what
they thought about Chess in Romania the
grand Chester in Bucharest and I think
you're going to like the reactions of
the chess fans
foreign
[Music]
thing about this tournament is that it
has a lot of volunteers now tell us a
bit about yourself my name is Andrei and
I am a volunteer here um
I knew it is a great tournament and I
wanted to be here to see the so many
good players and great matches and I am
very happy to be here do you play chess
as well or do you enjoy watching it as a
fan what is your experience with us yes
I play chess
for 10 years 10 years now since I was
six years old and I have a lot of
experience and
that was also great for me you've been
playing chess for quite a long time why
would you say your level is
medium but I want to be good as the
I want to be good to improve yes yes
for time to time no I know month year
yes yes and definitely being in the
presence of this like great chess
players will help you improve as well
your style what would you say is
comparable to which player you think is
comparable
I think firoza
because I admire him for a long time
because he is very young and when your
Grandmaster at a good age it is a
pleasure to you and I think my
I play like him thank you very much for
joining us it was a pleasure and thank
you for helping as a volunteer thank you
thank you
[Music]
2023 and the grand chess tour is back
for its eighth trip around the world
inspired by former world champion Gary
Kasparov the grantchester hosts the top
players to compete for top prizes eight
of the world's best joint tournament
wild cards and travel to four different
countries to fight for a 1.4 million
dollar prize fund the tour kicks off in
Bucharest Romania for the super bet
chess classic then things speed up as we
move to Warsaw Poland and Zagreb Croatia
for the first two rapid and Blitz events
the tour then makes its way to St Louis
Missouri for the final two events we're
back in November for the St Louis rapid
and Blitz and the illustrious sinkfield
cup when points are up for grabs the
best players show up who will be crowned
the new Champion find out when the grand
chess tour returns
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
thank you
no no
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to uh the final
moments of round three here in Bucharest
Romania one very important game has just
finished that is the game between yaneko
miyashi and our world champion dingley
rending welcome back to the show this
was a difficult game and everybody's
eyes was on this game yeah
how did you feel about the opening he
surprised you at the first move he
played D4 he played only E4 during the
world championship match did you expect
this at all uh not today but I had
prepared D4 during the World
Championship after he first employed it
in round three so actually I prepared
this line but today I I forgot the the
moves yup yup and let's go through the
game in fact take take E3 and you play
this move Bishop two F5 exactly what I
prepared
foreign
remember A5 was also good
and this idea with Knight F3 is magnus's
idea right with yes okay also probably
nine times white pieces before so you
knew the ins and outs of this protein
yeah opening
let's go A5
and this is the first moment I think you
started thinking
A4 and now Knight to D7 F4 yeah this is
a critical moment after Knight B1 has
become very bad already
um
yes
after work to C1 and Knight to B1
how are you feeling at this point I mean
there was so much pressure right now
nice to be one he was playing more or
less fast it felt like he knew what he's
doing
how are you feeling about first okay my
thought was after he played F4 well if
three promise became weak
although I had a double pump double pump
but heat pump also very weak so
yeah I might have some counter play on
Queen Side by Bishop C2 to place a
bishop to presume but then after bit 91
suddenly the night the bishop is under
attack yes did you miss this move Knight
to B1 yeah yeah before you played Bishop
C2 right yeah
and then you played you found this very
interesting idea what is the plan here
535 immediately to precipro to
production Bishop he had Bishop B5 and
uk5963
okay five and Knight to C3 right now
that makes a lot of sense okay because
we were thinking something on the fifth
rank after you played rookie five
against Knight to F5 and then take and
then some D4 ideas later on in the game
we weren't sure why you played this move
route to A5 so thank you for clarifying
that
um and he played Bishop E2
E5
you're seeing the evaluation yeah
here he can also play 92 yeah
is this what you're calculating yeah
yeah this one is
is difficult okay you still have some
opposite color Bishops but Knight to F5
you cannot move the
yeah yeah difficult difficult situation
but you fought on yeah and he played
this move Bishop to E2 were you feeling
that he's maybe misstepping at this
point
with his last few moves yeah he must
Miss Knight age
soon
yeah he could simply taking different
maybe but I I thought my position quite
bad I don't know how bad it is
and of course you don't have the
computer next to you during the game
right so he didn't know how good it is
either right and once you play this move
Knight away did you feel like you're
getting
enough initiative into the game after 98
since I have very clear plan 97 B5
before and
cannot play Bishop F3 you cannot stop
and prevent B5 I can play B5 anyway if
we take take and then before practice
just be better and now the Rook on A5
yeah
yeah very nice
okay and
he did Knight C3 Knight C7
King to F2 he played uh before I have to
stayed on my plan stay with your plan
yeah before here
yeah 27 one more time planned actually
yeah it's nice Bishop C4 have Bishop D2
if
Knight E3 a bishop did to uh Rook V8
foreign
yeah
so you played The Rook to D5
here Rook
um for 93
Rook B2
yeah behind this
so if you take Rook takes D5 now and
there's no Knight P6 Maybe
day two
uh at ah if you take with the bishop on
C4 here right after root to be yeah yeah
so this was a good move but you played
Rook takes D5
at the same time at this point and maybe
this was the last moment for him uh to
play the move G for and solidify cement
this Knight over file I saw G4 here were
you worried about it I I'm going pretty
safe accessory C3
a night so good play song F5 yeah how
did you assess this position
did you think you're yeah I think I was
worried about you for yeah yeah this
turns out to be quite bad yeah
but it's not that easy right and maybe
bishop to D2 here is also an idea
take on C4 and take on D5 you should be
to take 10 rupee one yeah yeah
but one thing and he did that during the
world championship match occasionally he
played very fast at the critical moments
and this is what he did as well
um were you happy when you saw this move
Bishop takes C4 on the board yeah I'm
quite happy
uh because I
oh I calculated until if we take on A4 I
have this bishop D2 Check Yes it's
pretty nice if I yeah pretty nice you
cannot go King D3 because the Rook can
take a look yeah that's very nice pretty
good and this one probably is just going
to be I mean you still have to defend it
but it's most likely going to be a truck
with a precise play it's quite easy to
do
yeah and he played Rook C4 and still it
wasn't easy even here right
Rook 31 and perhaps this was the last
moment he played this move Rook to B4
Rook to D1 which to my eyes looks very
artificial right it just doesn't make a
lot of sense
and then you can take the pump so if you
continue King six three or two D2 and
then but still you have your counter
play even here yeah
maybe H4
and if you go go here maybe H3 yeah I
can create some counter plane at least
yes yes it's not so easy to win not so
easy no no no I play quite quite clear
just to push the Palm on the king sides
some uh
A very wise man once said that uh all
the gun games are drawn maybe he was
right right this in this endgame hit
Palm Harbor very and not he doesn't have
any connect pump yeah yeah no very nice
um I think a good save for you
definitely how is how are your energy
levels
during the game I thought
why he plays this Knight B1
I feel
very tired
yeah for this tournament it actually
began at first I didn't want to
participate because I'm so tired
afterwards changing but now I'm
try to to hold try to
to continue to to pray you've showed
your resilience time and time again I
think uh congratulations on a good save
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next few rounds and right now we
have one game pending the big clash
between Duda and Dak we're going to go
on a short break and we'll be back soon
foreign
[Music]
Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of round three at the
Grand Chester opening event is underway
we have a couple of results yes we have
Fabiano caruana who defeated Maxima
shella Graf today that kind of a
miniature in fact and nepoding what an
exciting game that was truly nepo had
some marvelous opportunities and ding
once again this extraordinary resilience
right and ferozan rapper ended in a
Quick Draw quickish not much to say
about that one and Wesley Geary also an
interesting game but Wesley didn't
manage to get anything
from the Berlin yes yes exactly we have
one game remaining and it is the game
between Duda and diac we when we left
VAR we kind of thought that white had
something something he was upon up after
all but you can see from the expression
of Duda he's sitting there saying I'm a
pawn up but I have got nothing why is
that the case absolutely yeah sir I
think do that just simply misplayed his
position and the current position is
actually just uh is just going to be a
draw here he allowed black too much
activity now and I will show you that
why he cannot convert you there was one
big mistake he made in this position
here so if we we left off around here
yes
um where we were looking at the Knight
F6 and we were discussing some Rook C3
ideas and then idea of B4 B5 white has a
pretty nice advantages uh one and a half
Pawn Advantage at the moment but he
played rookie five which initially we
didn't like as much because Rook is not
really doing too much here C5 was a
preferred Square here and now after this
move Bishop to E6 he the only move uh
that to keep the advantage was just to
advance the pawn but I think he simply
probably missed this idea that he
thought Knight D5 is very strong and
if if you go to F2 it's very unpleasant
and but there is a really nice tactic
here yes sir Rook takes D5
Bishop takes D5 and now Knight C3 now
forking the rook and a bishop and this
is actually just simply winning for
white so due to the tactics now this
move Knight D5 doesn't work and that
makes a big difference now the next you
can try to activate your knight with
Knight F4 put the pawn on G4 and you
have a very comfortable and nice
Advantage here okay but instead he
played Rook D C1 and this looks very
passive and awkward and now Rook goes to
B2 now the B3 Pawn is under attack you
can never really push the pawn black
will simply take it you always have to
worry about the move Knight D5 as well
so now he played G4 and Knight D5 check
but it's much better to play Knight D5
and he did play Knight D5 yeah and now
let's see what are the options here so
he can play
King
D3 for example right but then I like the
smooth G5
securing the F4 Square for the Knight
and as we can see the knights are very
awkwardly placed here on C1 and E2 and
it's very hard to remove the Rook now
from between suddenly all of the black
pieces are very very active here and if
you try to go to
F2
for example then you run into the
problem of this move yeah that looks
passive yes and now King G3 Knight takes
E2 I'm losing the B3 takes C2 exchange
everything and black is just right
and time to pick up the pawn so King F2
has just been played and uh well I think
yeah we're just gonna see a draw after
the move Knight F4 a pretty incredible
hit so many good chances here but
completely blew it so Duda must be
really disappointed from after yesterday
game and now this game as well yeah the
combination of yesterday and today is
really a setback let's just remind
everybody first of all uh thank you for
joining us if you're joining us late
let's take a look at the games that
we've seen already we'll start with our
one of our tournament leaders we came
into today's round with three players
tied for first Wesley slow versus Anish
Gary it was one of these Berlin's and
the Berlin defense I tell you well Gary
Kasparov was on air explaining that
Vladimir kramnik did something
extraordinary in their world
championship match of 2000 as he really
showed the world that the Berlin defense
was this underrated defense it was
played in the 18th century and today I
did try something new with Bishop B4
exactly it's uh yeah Bishop B4 it kind
of seemed Bishop before ideas but really
off the Beaten Track Bishop E7 being the
dominant one so Wesley got well I want
to say a decent position right about
here and he played a move that was
unexpected he took we thought G4 might
have kept something something in the
position the players quickly got into a
Bishop's of opposite color position
in this game ended up petering out into
a draw a very well played draw better
draw nonetheless alireza farusia alireza
our grand Chester Champion a returning
Champion wants to do really well he's
the number one seed in the in the
competition he's up again played since
last single cup let's see which he won
which he won and a little rusty program
a little bit well uh Richie played the
Russian defense and said what have you
got and I have to say that alireza came
into the competition and into this game
and he said you know what here I am I'm
preparing for Richie and I suddenly
discover the guy plays everything you
know and his the move the variation the
defense that he prepared for most was
the French defense and he misguessed
and uh well after lots of moves and lots
of uh lots of Trades uh oh looks like
we're oh I think we're going to see uh
the green to a drop yeah
three versus three they'll find the
three move repetition and we'll bail out
to a handshake DX saves his second game
with black
first one against Fabiano in the first
round exactly you see it's sort of like
he he seizes the defensive and he hangs
on uh grimly determinably and uh
makes his draw and the players are
repeating and this will be our fourth
draw of this round three only Fabi made
a victory so we're going to end up with
four players
tied for first yeah if I be joined the
leaders today so
and here are our standings yes we have
four co-leaders habiano Carolina
Richard Robert
all sitting handsomely with a plus one
and then with 50 think liran and Anish
giri
and with one point ferocia and bl Duda
and diak with mvl our defending champion
from the Bucharest
2022 event it's kind of strange to see
him at the bottom half of the Cross
table but he'll be back they'll be back
exactly and looking forward to tomorrow
what pairings do we have in mind right
let's say the pairings we have MPL
against giri looking to snap back
Rapport against so this is our two
leaders playing each other tomorrow very
nice and diak against firuja
ding against Judah I think tomorrow yeah
I was about to say yeah to the the four
co-leaders all playing against each
other heavyweight clash between Fabi and
nepo tomorrow uh right well if Abby
getting two whites in a row he might be
saying okay this is very very nice
sweet as we'll look forward to that uh
uh oh yeah
wow wow look it's look at the Christian
and the darouch I look happy they do
they do uh yeah so far in the first
three games uh the world champion from
China Dean Lauren has not really shown
his A-game not yet but he's warmed up
now yes let's hope so and VAR bring the
broadcast home for us what's your final
thoughts of uh this round three very
interesting ground yes sir and
definitely the highlight of the round
was the fabi's very quick and convincing
Victory against mvl he looked out of
shape in this uh in this game particular
and made some really bad moves but Fabi
still was very accurate and to convert
and Duda is another case it must be very
disappointed two days in a row here he
got really good opportunities today to
try to get his first win but he
completely blew it so I'm excited to see
what tomorrow is going to bring we got
the leaders playing each other should be
very interesting Yasser
absolutely and let's go to Bucharest and
Christian for final thoughts of this
round three
and just to build up on what you
mentioned VAR indeed Fabiano is
definitely having the wind blowing in
his cells important Victory and tomorrow
with the white pieces he's going to try
to put a lot of pressure on his
co-leader Jan napomiyashi who must be
disappointed uh because of course he got
a winning position out of the opening
just brilliant play out of the opening
against uh his foe ding Lee Rand who he
knows so very well and he let Escape so
many times in the last few weeks so
definitely disappointing Fabiano
definitely not disappointed so I think
this one is going to be a huge Clash we
have very exciting matchups coming your
way tomorrow absolutely round Fort is is
going to be a clash yeah
thank you so much for sharing your day
with us I hope you're enjoying the
broadcast and actually you're just
YouTube terrific too of course we'll see
you all tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited